WHILE AGO MORE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED.
ONE I THINK EVERYONE HERE TODAY.
AND THAT THANK MY MY COLLEAGUE
FOR. WORKING TO PUT THIS
TOGETHER AND HIS TEAM.
.
AND HAPPY NEW YEARS EVERYONE.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM THE AIR BE AND OTHERS
TO BE REGARDING THE PROGRESS AIR
BE IS MAKING. TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES.
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC
AIR TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANTS.
AND TO IMPROVE PUBLIC DATA ON
THESE THE MISSIONS AS WE WORK TO
REDUCE THEM TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
WELL THEY GOING TO COVER AIR
BASE PLAN TO MEET THE TWENTY
THIRTY GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS AS
REFLECTED IN THE RECENTLY
ADOPTED SCHOOL BEING PLAN.
WHICH GIVES US THE CHANCE TO
REVIEW THE ROLE OF CAP AND TRADE
AS WELL AS THE RANGE OF DIRECT
EMISSION REDUCTION MEASURES
WHICH WILL BE NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THE FORTY PERCENT
ADDITIONAL REDUCTION.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS OF THE PASS AB THE
NAME THE EIGHT LAST YEAR.
LAST JULY ABOUT AN OVERSUPPLY
OF ALLOWANCE SAYS AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THE IMPACT THAT THIS
MAY HAVE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY OF THAT MISSION CAP.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
I'M ANXIOUS TO HEAR HOW THE AIR
BE WILL MANAGE IT.
HOWEVER I THINK WE ALL NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WITH THEIR HEART
PRICE CEILING ON ALLOWANCES.
INDIA THIRTY AIR BE HAVE TO
SOLID DECISIONAL MONOPOLY
ALLOWANCES AT THE SAME PRICE.
WE REALLY DON'T HAVE A HARD CAP
ON EMISSIONS IN THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM.
AND WE MOST LIKELY DID NOT HAVE
THE MISSION CAPS ON INDIVIDUAL
FACILITIES.
THIS MAKES IT ALL THE MORE
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP FOCUS ON
THE DIRECT EMISSIONS REDUCTION
MEASURES AS A PRIMARY TWELVE TO
ACHIEVE THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET.
AND THAT THEY ARE BEACON TO NEED
TO PURSUE ADDITIONAL AND ENHANCE
MEASURES TO ACHIEVE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT'S ALSO ALL THE MORE REASON TO
MAKE SURE THAT AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTED EFFECTIVELY. TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS AND OUR MOST
POLLUTED BURNING COMMUNITIES.
AIR BE AND THEY ARE DISTRICTS
NEED TO MAKES.
NAY TO BE AGGRESSIVE AND
CREATIVE AS THEY DEVELOP MASTERS
TO RESERVE DECADES A NEGLECT IN
THESE COMMUNITIES.
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THAT HAVE
BEEN TO ELECT A WASTELAND ALL MY
LIFE LONGER.
AT THE SAME TIME WE SHOULD NOT
BE MAKING MATTERS WORSE RAISING
CAP AND TRADE REVENUE TO FIND
HOUSING EDGY SINCE NEXT TO
FREEWAYS.
AS IMPORTANT AS A B. SIX
SEVENTEEN IS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT IT DOES NOT REPLACE THE
FUNDAMENTAL OBLIGATION THAT AIR
BEHALF ON THEIR AB THIRTY TO. TO
ENSURE THAT MEASURES TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
COMPLIMENTS AIR QUALITY AND THE
NOT LEAD TO LOCAL INCREASES IN
OUR POLLUTION.
WE LONG RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF EQUITY IN OUR CLIMATE
POLICIES AND WE KNOW THAT
TRICKLE DOWN ENVIRONMENTALISM
HAS SPILLED COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE FOR THAT KATE'S.
WE MADE SOME GOOD PROGRESS BUT
MUCH WORK REMAINS TO WISH I
REMAIN SO SURE THAT OUR CLIMATE
AND OUR POLICIES WORK
EFFECTIVELY. TOGETHER AND NOT
ONLY SERVE AS A MODEL FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD BUT ALSO FOR
THE MOST NOTABLE HERE AT HOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WOULD HAVE MEANT
CHAIRED WELCOME EVERYONE AGAIN.
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE CHANGE IN
THE NATURAL RESOURCES.
JOINT HEARING.
THANK AND WELCOME MY COLLEAGUES
ARE HERE AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
ALL OF YOU THAT HAVE TAKEN THE
TIME TO BE HERE AS WELL.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE JOINED
BY THE CHAIR OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD MARY NICHOLS FOR
THIS DISCUSSION TODAY.
AND HER TEAM.
ALONG WITH ROSS BROWN FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
YOU ALL KNOW THE SCOPING PLAN.
IS CALIFORNIA'S ROADMAP FOR
ACHIEVING OUR AMBITIOUS TWENTY
THIRTY EMISSION TARGETS.
THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
STATE AGENCIES THE LEGISLATURE
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SHARE
A COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PLAN. TO MOVE OUR STATE FORWARD
WITH A R. B. IS THE STATE AND
IT'S TAKING THE LEAD AGENCY ARE
IN IMPLEMENTING THE STRATEGIES.
IT WILL TAKE ALL OF US.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THE.
PLAN WORKS IN THAT WE MEET OUR
TARGETS.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE BEEN
TRACKING DEVELOPMENT OF THE
SCOPING PLAN KNOW THAT REACHING
OUR TWENTY THIRTY TARGET. IS A
BIG CHALLENGE.
IT WILL REQUIRE MORE AMBITIOUS
ACTIONS THAN. EVER BEFORE.
SO WHILE WE LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
HEARING IN THE POLICY PACKAGE
AIR BE HAS PUT TOGETHER FOR THIS
PLAN. HOUSEHOLD WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT ADDITIONAL
ACTIONS
RESPECTIVE OR POLICIES MAY BE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE OUR MISSION
STAY ON TRACK.
FOR EXAMPLE ON THE SAME DAY THAT
WE HEARD THE SCOPE OF PLAN. AIR
BE ALSO HEARD UPDATES FROM STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS ON THE
PROPOSED.
S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE
TARGETS.
DESPITE THEIR BEST EFFORTS
EVERYONE AGREED THAT MORE
AMBITIOUS TARGETS FOR S. B.
THREE SONY FIVE. ARE FEASIBLE AT
THIS TIME.
HOWEVER WE KNOW THATSHIFTING
LAND USE AND TRANSPORTATION
PARENT IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
REACHING A TWENTY THIRTY GOAL.
PART TODAY'S DISCUSSION COULD BE
ABOUT WHETHER ADDITIONAL POLICY
INTERVENTIONS MAY BE NECESSARY.
TO HELP ENSURE OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS HAVE WHAT
THEY NEED TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
STATE EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE COMES FROM THE
BOARD OF COMMISSIONS THAT HELPED
BY THE STATE IN AN ONGOING WAY.
THERE BE HAS MADE STRIDES AND
GREAT STRIDES WITH ADDITION OF
TWO NEW MEMBERS OF FOCUS ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
CONTINUED CONVENING. OF THE
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE
BUT OTHER STATE AGENCIES LIKE
THE STREET TO GO COUNCIL.
LACTOSE PERSPECTIVE STEM.
MIGHT BE TIME FOR US TO CONSIDER
HOW WE BETTER INSTITUTIONALIZE
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES IN ALL
AREAS OF GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE A FULL PICTURE. OF
WHAT IS WORKING AND WHAT ISN'T
WORKING IN OUR COMMUNITY SO WE
CAN TAKE TIMELY AND EFFECTIVE
ACCESS TO SUPPORT. OUR STATE
GOALS AGAIN I WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE OUR COLLEAGUES THAT ARE
HERE AND THOSE OF YOU WHO WILL
BE PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING.
QUITE THEM CALL THE FIRST.
PRESENTER MRS AYE PANICLES.
AND OUT ROSS BROWN.
IS IT IS.
YEAH PERFECT POTS CARP OUR FIRST
PANEL TO A COME UP TO THE TABLE.
THANK YOU AND THANKS TO BOTH OF
THE CHAIRS AND ALL THE MEMBERS
WHO ARE HERE.
MY NAME IS MARY NICHOLS AND I
AM THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME THAT CARP HAS
PRESENTED IN FRONT OF THESE
COMMITTEES BUT I AM PARTICULARLY
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY.
TO TALK ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB ONE NINETY SEVEN. TO
DISCUSS THE STATE'S PROGRESS ON
AIR QUALITY IN THE EMISSIONS
TRANS. AND THE TWENTY THIRTY
SCOPING PLAN AND I WANT TO SORT
OF SKETCH OUT SOME OF THE
CONTEXT THAT THIS IS ALL. ABOUT
TAKING PLACE WHERE THEY HAD.
FIRST OF ALL LOOKING OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED AND THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED A SERIES OF BILLS THAT
ADDRESS EMISSIONS IN
COMMUNITIES.
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
AND GREENHOUSE GASES AND THESE
IN AND OF THEMSELVES EACH ONE OF
THEM. ARE IS A LANDMARK PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT IS WORTH
CELEBRATING.
OUR WORK AT CAR. GOES BACK FIFTY
YEARS IN FACT WE'RE CELEBRATING
OUR FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS
YEAR. AND WE WERE CREATED WITH
THE GOALS AND ATTAINING AND
MAINTAINING HEALTHY AIR QUALITY.
OVER THE YEARS ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES WERE ADDED WITH
RESPECT TO EXPOSURE TO TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS AND MOST RECENTLY
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES. EACH
WITH A SORT OF SEPARATE SET OF.
REQUIREMENTS THAT WENT ALONG
WITH THEM BUT ACROSS THE BOARD
OF WE HAVE TRIED AT CAR. AND
HAVE IN MANY WAYS I THINK I HAVE
BEEN OF A NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL OUT LEADER IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES TO MEETING. AIR
QUALITY RULES AND REGULATIONS.
LET ME TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW WE'VE DONE FIRST OF ALL WITH
RESPECT TO AIR QUALITY THE THING
THAT MOST.
BUT DIRECTLY AFFECTS HUMAN
HEALTH.
USEPA SETS HEALTH BASED
STANDARDS AND IT'S REQUIRED BY
FEDERAL LAW TO REVIEW THOSE
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE. SUFFICIENTLY HEALTH
PROTECTIVE BASED ON THE LATEST
SCIENCE
AND WE PROVIDE INPUT TO THAT
PROCESS.
THIS IS LED TO A SERIES OF
INCREASINGLY STRINGENT STANDARDS
OVER TIME THAT REFLECT THE
IMPROVED.
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW AIR
POLLUTION ATTACKS PUBLIC HEALTH.
OXIDES OF NITROGEN.
CALLED KNOCKS ARE THE KEY SMOG
FORMING POLLUTANTS THAT WE ARE
NOW WORKING TO CONTROL. AND IN
YOUR HANDOUT YOU HAVE A CHART
THAT SHOWS CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS
IN REDUCING THE KNOCKS THAT
LEADS TO FORMING HAVE SMOG. AND
AS THE.
EVIDENCE FROM OUR STATEWIDE AIR
MEASUREMENTS
THE CURRENTLY DROPS FROM LEFT TO
RIGHT SHOWS KNOCKS EMISSIONS
DECREASING NEARLY SEVENTY
PERCENT SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. BASED ON REGULATIONS
ADOPTED TODAY.
THIS PROGRESS REFLECTS THE
BENEFITS OF BOTH CARB AND EPA
PROGRAMS FOR MOBILE SOURCES AS
WELL AS THEIR DISTRICT PROGRAMS
FOR STATIONARY SOURCES.
BECAUSE MOBILE SOURCES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR EIGHTY PERCENT
OF KNOCKS EMISSIONS MORE
STRINGENT ENGINE STANDARDS
CLEANER FUELS AN INCENTIVE
FUNDING HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE
FOR A LARGE PORTION OF THIS
PROGRESS.
FOR EXAMPLE EMISSIONS FROM A NEW
CAR THAT COULD BE OFFERED FOR
SALE TODAY ARE NINETEEN NINE
PERCENT CLEANER. THAN A CAR FROM
THE EARLY NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
THIS PROGRESS IS IN RESPONSE TO
AIR POLLUTANT FUEL STANDARDS
ADOPTED BY CAR AS WELL AS
INNOVATION THAT HAS BEEN
CATALYZED BY STRINGENT
STANDARDS.
THAT WERE DEVELOPED THROUGH A
PUBLIC PROCESS AND IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH RIGOROUS ENFORCEMENT. AS
YOU KNOW THE STANDARD SET
HEARING CALIFORNIA COPY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD SO PEOPLE WELL BEYOND OUR
BORDERS BENEFIT FROM
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN
AIR. AND I THINK IT IS WORTH
POINTING OUT HERE THAT THIS
PROGRESS IN ABSOLUTE MEASURE
BACKDROP OF GROWTH OF POPULATION
GROWTH THE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED BY AND OF COURSE OF
GROWTH OF OUR ECONOMY SO IN.
RELATIVE TERMS IT'S AN EVEN
MORE AYE SERIOUS A TASK THAT WE
ACCOMPLISH THEN MIGHT SEEM I
JUST ON THE FACE OF IT.
CARBON THE DISTRICTS OF ALSO
WORK TO REDUCE RISK FROM
EXPOSURE TO AIR POLLUTION THAT
IS TOXIC THAT IS.
CHEMICALS THAT HAVE AND
IMMEDIATE.
DIRECT EFFECT ON EITHER.
PRODUCING OUR SHORT TERM.
FACTS OR THAT ARE ACKERSON
AGENTS AND THESE INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES INCLUDE REFINERIES AS
WELL AS SMALLER SOURCES LIKE GAS
STATIONS AND MOBILE SOURCES OF
WHICH THE LARGEST IS DIESEL
HEAVY DIESEL ARE. PARTICULATE.
CALIFORNIA'S AIR TOXIC PROGRAM
BEGAN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
WITH ADOPTION OF THE TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT IDENTIFICATION AND
CONTROL ACT SO WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING.
WITH TALKS SAYS SINCE THAT TIME
THE STATE HAS IDENTIFIED OVER
TWO HUNDRED SUBSTANCES THAT ARE
HAZARDOUS TO HUMAN HEALTH
INCLUDING LEAD BENZENE TAL YOU
IN AN ASBESTOS.
WE'VE ALSO ADOPTED NUMEROUS
REGULATIONS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
AND EXPOSURE TO THESE POLLUTANTS
INCLUDING PHASING OUT THE USE OF
CARCINOGENS FROM DRY CLEANERS BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND
SUBSTANTIALLYLIMITING THE
LEVELS OF BENZENE IN GASOLINE
TODAY THE STATE'S EFFORTS
INCLUDE FOCUSING ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS OF DIESEL PARTICULATE.
WHICH ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT SEVENTY
PERCENT OF THE KNOWN CANCER RISK
RELATED TO TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT
SO BY FAR THE LARGEST.
THE LARGEST SHARE. IN YOUR
HANDOUTS YOU ALSO HAVE A CHART
THAT SHOWS PROGRESS IN REDUCING
DIESEL PARTICULATE.
DIESEL UP PARTICULATE EMISSIONS
HAVE DECREASED APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTY PERCENT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY IN RESPONSE TO A SERIES
OF REGULATIONS VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS AN INCENTIVE BASED
PROGRAMS THAT CARD IS
IMPLEMENTED. MOBILE SOURCES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NINETY PERCENT
OF TALKS OR TOXIC DIESEL SO
MOBILE SOURCE PROGRAMS ARE
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THAT HAS
OCCURRED.
AND OVER THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS STATEWIDE EMISSIONS A SAY
SEE AND ASSOCIATED HEALTH
IMPACTS FROM AIR TOXICS HAVE
BEEN REDUCED BY ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THESE R.
STATEWIDE NUMBERS AND OBVIOUSLY.
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE AND
YOU I KNOW ARE GONNA WHAT WANNA
TALK ABOUT MORE. BUT THE
EXAMPLES THAT I GAVE FOR KNOX
AND DIESEL ARE INDICATIVE OF THE
TRANS ACROSS THE STATE FOR A
WHOLE VARIETY OF POLLUTANTS THAT
ARE. ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
HANDOUTS THAT WE PROVIDED.
IN GENERAL EMISSIONS HAVE BEEN
TRENDING DOWN FOR CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS AND GREENHOUSE
GASES DUE TO A WHOLE SERIES OF
LOCAL AND STATE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. PLUS INCREASINGLY
IN RECENT YEARS INCENTIVES AND
OTHER KINDS OF INITIATIVES.
OVER THE LAST FIFTY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED CLEAN AIR
REGULATIONS AND PROGRAMS I HAD
NEVER. COUNTED THEM UP BEFORE WE
STARTED TO GET READY FOR THIS
HEARING. THESE REGULATIONS RANGE
FROM SETTING VEHICLE EMISSION
STANDARDS REQUIREMENTS FOR FEELS
AS WELL AS REQUIRING DIFFERENT
FORMULATIONS FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
MEANWHILE WILD CARD HAS BEEN
DOING ITS WORK BOUT WITH AT
POLLUTANTS AYE THAT ARE EMITTED
FROM MOBILE SOURCES AND FEELS.
AIR DISTRICTS ARE HAVE HAD THE
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
DEALING WITH INDUSTRIAL SOURCES
AND THEY HAVE MADE A
CONTRIBUTION TO THIS PROGRESS AS
WELL. INCLUDING USING CATALYTIC
CONTROLS ON POWER PLANTS LOW
KNOCKS BOILERS AT REFINERIES AS
AND ELSEWHERE. AND CLEANER
COMBUSTION FOR SPACE HEATING AS
WELL.
NOW.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT TO BE
PROUD OF IN THESE NUMBERS
ENTRANCE THE AIR IS CLEANER
STATEWIDE THIRTY THOUSAND.
PREMATURE DEATHS ARE AVOIDED
EVERY YEAR.
AND ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CASES OF ASTHMA HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY AS WELL.
AND ALL THE WHILE OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA HAS CONTINUED TO BE
THE SIX OR SOMETIMES THE FIFTH
OR FOURTH.
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
BUT TO BE CLEAR THERE IS MUCH
WORK AHEAD OF US.
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION RESIDENTS STILL LIVING
COMMUNITIES THAT EXCEED THE
FEDERAL HEALTH STANDARDS.
EXPOSURE TO DIESEL PARTICULATE
IS TOO HIGH.
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE LOCATED NEAR FREIGHT
FACILITIES SUCH AS PORTS
RAILYARDS AND DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS.
IN RESPONSE TO AB ONE NINETY
SEVENS DIRECTION TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AM PUBLIC ACCESS
TWO EMISSIONS AND INVENTORY
DATA.
CARB DEVELOPED THE POLLUTION
MAPPING TOOL.
THIS MAPPING TOOL ALLOWS USERS
TO IDENTIFY AND COMPARE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS CRITERIA
POLLUTANT AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANT EMISSIONS OF
FACILITIES THAT REPORT USING OUR
MANDATORY GREENHOUSE GAS
REPORTING PROGRAM. USING THIS
TOOL A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC CAN
ZOOM IN AND EXAMINE EMISSIONS
WITH IN A PARTICULAR COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE A VIDEO DEMONSTRATION
THAT KIDNAPPED THAT WE WANT TO
SHOW YOU. IN JUST A MINUTE AYE I
HOPE YOU'LL FIND IT INTERESTING
BUT BEFORE WE SHOW THE VIDEO. I
WANT TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND.
THE EMISSIONS DATA THAT'S USED
IN THIS TO ALL WAS EXPANDED IN
RESPONSE TO AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
AND CONTAINS AN ESTIMATE OF
ANNUAL EMISSIONS OF GREENHOUSE
GASES AS WELL AS CRITERIA. AND
TOXIC EMISSIONS ON A FACILITY
BASIS FOR THE LARGEST FACILITIES
IN THE STATE.
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
DATA ARE COLLECTED BY THE LOCAL
I'M SORRY I COLLECTED THROUGH
CART WAS MANDATORY REPORTING
PROGRAM. THE CRITERIA.
EXCUSE ME THE CRITERIA AND TOXIC
AIR EMISSIONS DATA ARE COLLECTED
BY THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS.
IT'S USEFUL DATA BUT IT DOES
HAVE SOME WEAKNESSES FOR EXAMPLE
DISTRICTS USE VARYING
METHODOLOGIES AND DATA
COLLECTION PRACTICES FOR
REPORTING CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
AND AIR TOXIC EMISSIONS.
SOMETIMES EVEN FROM THE SAME
SOURCES.
WE'RE WORKING ON HARMONIZING
REPORTING METHODS AS PART OF THE
AB SIX SEVENTEEN PROCESS BUT WE
STILL HAVE A WAYS TO GO.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS THAT SOME
FACILITIES MAY REPORT CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS EVERY THREE YEARS
BECAUSE OF LOCAL AIR DISTRICT
REPORTING THRESHOLDS. AND AIR
TOXIC EMISSIONS ONLY EVERY FOUR
YEARS BASED ON THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT HOTSPOTS PROGRAM SO
THERE'S AN UNEVENNESS IN THE
DATA. IT'S NOT ALL EQUALLY
TIMELY AND AS I SAID THIS I'VE
SOMETIMES COLLECTED IN USING
DIFFERENT CRITERIA.
BUT NEVERTHELESS WE THINK THIS
TOOL WILL ELP OUT FOR ONE THING
BECAUSE I THINK IT'LL CREATE A
DEMAND FOR MORE DATA AND MORE
TIMELY DATA.
AND IT WILL HELP COMMUNITIES TO
TRACK TRENDS FROM FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE SAY AND COMPARE
UP BY REGION AND BY FACILITY.
SO THE FIRST YEAR WE STARTED
COLLECTING GREENHOUSE GAS
DATABUS TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
SINCE THEN SOME FACILITIES HAVE
SEEN EMISSIONS INCREASES AS
CALIFORNIA GREW OUT OF ITS
RECESSION.
WHILE OTHERS
HAVE A SCENE.
DECREASES.
AND.
THIS IS INTERESTING TO LOOK AT
IN OF ITSELF.
BUT YOU'LL SEE THAT EMISSIONS
VERY FROM YEAR TO YEAR FOR
INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES WHICH IS
NOT SURPRISING CONSIDERING THAT
THERE ARE MANY ECONOMIC
TECHNICAL AND REGULATORY FACTORS
THAT INFLUENCE OF FACILITIES
EMISSIONS.
NOTE THAT EMISSIONS FROM
STATIONARY FACILITIES ARE
SUBJECT TO LIMITS THAT ARE
ENFORCED BY LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS.
WE EXPECT THAT ONE OF THE USES
OF THIS TOOL IS GOING TO HELP
INFORM COMMUNITY EFFORTS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND EMISSIONS FROM
MULTIPLE SOURCES THAT MAY BE
IMPACTING A PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY.
AND TO HELP PRIORITIZE WHERE
MORE ACTION IS NEEDED.
ENHANCED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
UNDER AB SIX AT SIX SEVENTEEN AS
WELL AS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COMMUNITY ACTION PLANS. WILL
HELP PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING WHAT EACH
FACILITY IS DOING AND HELP DRIVE
DOWN EMISSIONS IN THOSE AREAS
THAT ARE MOST IMPACTED. SO WE
HAVE THIS BRIEF VIDEO
DEMONSTRATION WHICH IF THE
TECHNOLOGY WORKS
WILL SHOW OFF SOME OF THE.
SOME OF THE SEARCH FEATURES
THAT THIS TOOL HAS TO OFFER.
AND MY ASSISTANT.
WILL THAT OUTLOOK BUT. PLAY THE
VIDEO CARBON.
AN INTERACTIVE WEB BASED MAPPING
TOOL THAT DISPLAYS THE LOCATIONS
OF LARGE FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THERE GREENHOUSE
GAS CRITERIA AND TOXIC POLLUTANT
COMMISSIONS.
THIS ONLINE TOOL ALLOWS USERS TO
FIND AIR POLLUTION SOURCES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY QUANTIFY THEIR
EMISSIONS AND CHART THE EMISSION
TRENDS OVER TIME.
LET'S START BY TAKING A LOOK AT
THE MAIN USER INTERFACE WHICH
CONSISTS OF THREE PANELS.
BUT CONTROL PANEL BUT DISPLAY
PANEL. AT FACILITY LIST PANEL.
THE CONTROL PANEL ALLOWS USERS
TO SEARCH FACILITIES BY FACILITY
NAME STREET ADDRESS GEOGRAPHIC
REGION LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT. OR
ANY OF MANY OTHER ATTRIBUTES.
IT ALSO LETS USERS SELECT THE
POLLUTANTS AND THE YEARS FOR
WHICH DATA WILL BE DISPLAYED.
THE DISPLAY PANEL SHOWS THE
LOCATIONS OF THE FACILITIES ON A
MAP AND USERS ARE ABLE TO PAN
AND ZOOM THE MAP.
FACILITIES ARE COLOR CODED BASED
ON THEIR PRIMARY SECTOR.
THE RIGHT SIDE BAR DISPLAYS A
LIST OF FACILITIES ALONG WITH
THEIR EMISSIONS THAT CORRESPONDS
TO THE FILTER SELECTED IN THE
SEARCH MENU.
NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
INFORMATION THE TOOL CAN
PROVIDE.
USING THE TOOL SEARCH FEATURE
WILL WORK FOR THE PHILLIPS SIXTY
SIX REFINERY IN WILMINGTON.
BUT NOTICE THAT THE LISTA
FACILITIES HAS SHORTENED TO
INCLUDE ONLY THOSE WITH PHILLIPS
SIXTY SIX IN THEIR NAME.
CLICKING ON THE FACILITY NAME IN
THIS LIST
SHOWS THE FACILITIES LOCATION ON
THE MAP. AND OPENS IT
INFORMATION WINDOW.
THIS WINDOW CAN ALSO BE OPEN BY
CLICKING DIRECTLY ON ANY
FACILITY MARKER ON THE MAP.
NOTICE THAT THE WINDOW HAS SIX
TABS.
THE FIRST TAB SHOWS BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE FACILITY.
THE EMISSIONS TAB SHOWS A TABLE
OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS CRITERIA
AND TOXIC POLLUTANT MISSIONS
REPORTED IN THE MOST CURRENT
INVENTORY YEAR.
THE GHG TREND AND CRITERIA TRjN
TABS SO THE TREND OF THE
FACILITIES EMISSIONS OVER TIME
ALONG WITH THE TABLE AND
EMISSIONS REPORTED FOR EACH
YEAR.
THE TOXIC STAB PRESENTS A
SUMMARY OF EMISSIONS FOR EIGHT
POLLUTANTS THAT ARE
REPRESENTATIVE OF SUBSTANCES
COMMONLY EMITTED AND HIGHER
VOLUMES OR THOSE WITH THE
POTENTIAL FOR SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
IMPACTS.
LASTLY THE COMPARE TAB ALLOWS
USERS TO PLUG GREENHOUSE GAS
CRITERIA AND TOXIC POLLUTANT
TRENDS ON THE SAME CHART.
NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT TWO
VERY USEFUL FEATURES OF THE
TOOL.
FIRST GALLON VIRUS CREAM MAP
PLAYERS ARE AVAILABLE TO HELP
USERS LOCATE FACILITIES WITHIN
THE CONTEXT OF CALIFORNIA'S
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
USERS CAN CHOOSE TO DISPLAY ALL
CENSUS TRACT IN THE STATE.
ARE ONLY THOSE AND CALLIN VIRUS
SCREENS TOP TWENTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE.
ON THIS MAP LAYER DARK RED
INDICATES A COMMUNITY THAT IS
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY POLLUTION
POOR POOR SOCIAL ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS. WHILE DARK GREEN
INDICATES A COMMUNITY THAT IS
NOT SUBSTANTIALLY AFFECTED BY
THESE FACTORS.
NEXT
THE SHAPE OPTIONS IN THE TOUR
ALLOW USERS TO SELECT SEVERAL
FACILITIES AT ONCE USE IN A
CIRCLE A RECTANGLE OR A POLY
GONE.
A PERSON LIVING IN A COMMUNITY
CAN USE THIS FEATURE TO ASSESS
THE CUMULATIVE EMISSIONS FROM
FACILITIES NEAR THEM.
HE IS IN THE RECTANGLE TOOL
USERS CONTRIVED PERIMETER AROUND
A CENSUS TRACT OR OTHER AREA OF
INTEREST.
WHEN USERS CLICK IN THE SHADED
AREA THE TOOL OPENS A POPUP
WINDOW DISPLAYING GEOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE AREA AND
THE NUMBER OF FACILITIES AND IT.
OTHER TABS DISPLAY A LIST OF THE
FACILITIES IN THE SELECTED AREA.
THERE AGGREGATED EMISSIONS THE
G. H. G.. CRITERIA.
PENTOXIDE POLLUTANT COMMISSION
TRANS.
AND A CHART THAT ALLOWS TRjN
COMPARISONS ACROSS PROGRAMS.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR BRIEF
DEMONSTRATION OF THE POLLUTION
MAPPING TOOL. IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE TO MEET OUR AB ONE
NINETY SEVEN REQUIREMENTS PLEBE
PLAN TO ANNUALLY UPDATE THE TOOL
BUT THE MOST RECENT EMISSIONS
DATA EACH SPRING.
THAT'S IT.
I WISH IT WERE LARGER BUT.
AT A COMPUTER SCREEN IS PRETTY
EASY TO. TO FOLLOW THE DAY THAT
IT WASN'T REALLY DESIGNED I
GUESS FOR THE FOR THE LARGE
SCREEN BUT AB IT IS EASY TO
ACCESS AND.
HOPEFULLY YOU'LL HAVE AN
OCCASION TO DO THAT AT SOME
POINT.
JERRY.
YES THIS IS ONLY THE SOURCES
THAT ARE UNDER.
GREENHOUSE GAS REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS SALAD STATION IN
THE LARGEST THE LARGEST
FACILITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE TO REPORT
THEIR GHGS WE'VE NOW LAYERED
INTO THAT THEIR TOXICS AND
THEY'RE ON CONVENTIONAL AIR
POLLUTION EMISSIONS. UP IT WOULD
BE.
USEFUL AND INTERESTING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT PUT IN ROADWAYS
OR COMMUNITIES THOSE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL LAYERS AND A SORT OF
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE
STARTED TO DO IN THE BEGINNING
BUT CLEARLY THAT GEOGRAPHY OF
THAT IS ALSO. IS ALSO VERY
INTERESTING.
SO I'M. AS I WAS SAYING BEFORE
THE.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN NOW REALLY.
EXPANDS OUR.
A ARBY'S. INTERACTIONS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
IS CERTAINLY HAS BEEN THE FIRST
AND MOST SIGNIFICANT LEGISLATION
ADDRESSING CRITERIA POLLUTANT
AND TOXIC EMISSIONS SINCE THE
DAYS OF AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHT.
EIGHTY EIGHT IN THE LATE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
THIS LEGISLATION FOCUSES ON
ADDRESSING ISSUES IN OUR MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
IT ALSO REQUIRES CARP TO DEVELOP
A STATE STRATEGY THAT OUTLINES
MEASURES TO FURTHER REDUCE
CRITERIA POLLUTANT AND AIR
TOXICS EMISSIONS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
DEVELOP COMMUNITY MONITORING
GUIDANCE AND REQUIRE ENHANCED
EMISSIONS REPORTING FROM
STATIONARY SOURCES. THE BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT WHILE THE STATE
HAS SEEN TREMENDOUS IMPROVEMENT
AT THE REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE
LEVEL THERE ARE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE. THAT ARE
REMAINING DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY POOR AIR QUALITY AND
THAT IT IS THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT REQUIRE SPECIAL ATTENTION
AND ACTION. AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IMPROVING THE INVENTORY IS GONNA
BE A KEY COMPONENT OF ANY NEW
STRATEGIES THAT WE WILL BE.
THAT WILL BE DEVELOPING.
SO AB ONE NINETY SEVEN AND AB
SIX SEVENTEEN REALLY WORK HAND
IN HAND TO SUPPORT A FOCUSED
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS APPROACH.
TO THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. NOW TURNING TO THE
SCOPING PLAN THAT WE ADOPTED AT
OUR LAST BOARD MEETING.
WE HAVE BEEN.
ALSO HARD AT WORK IN DEVELOPING
AND UPDATING AND IMPLEMENTING.
THE CLIMATE CHANGE SCOPING PLAN
THIS PLAN WAS DEVELOPED THROUGH
A PUBLIC PROCESS AND RECEIVED
CONSIDERABLE. LEGISLATIVE INPUT
OVER TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND
WEST UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED AT OUR
DECEMBER BOARD HEARING.
STAKEHOLDER SUPPORT FOR ITS
APPROVAL WAS OVERWHELMING.
THIS IS THE STATE'S THIRD
SCOPING PLAN AND WE'VE MADE
GREAT PROGRESS IN REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SINCE
THE FIRST PLAN WAS ADOPTED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. BUT AGAIN
WE'VE ALSO ADOPTED MORE
STRINGENT AND.
AMBITIOUS GOALS AND.
HAVE A LOT MORE WORK AHEAD OF
US.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING
PLAN CONTINUES THE APPROACH OF
USING A MIX OF REGULATIONS
INCENTIVES AND MARKET BASED
MECHANISMS.
AS THE WHICH SUCH AS THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM TO ACHIEVE R. S.
B. THIRTY TWO.
GOALS.
USING A COMPREHENSIVE MIX OF
STRATEGIES AS DESCRIBED IN THE
SCOPING CLAN. WE'RE BUILDING ON
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THE PAST
TEN YEARS.
BUT THE SCOPING PLAN ALSO
PROVIDES.
CERTAINTY. AS MUCH AS CERTAINTY
IS AVAILABLE CONSIDERING THE
VARIATIONS IN.
GLOBAL EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGIES
AND OTHER TRANS.
INCLUDING THE ECONOMY.
IT ALSO DELIVERS A NUMBER OF
C! BENEFITS AND RESULTS IN A
PROGRAM THAT MEETS THE TEST OF
BEING COST EFFECTIVE. AND OF
ATTRACTING UP PARTNERS ACROSS
THE GLOBE WHICH WAS ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL OBJECTIVES OF AB THIRTY
TWO. AND WHICH WE BELIEVE IS
IMPORTANT BOTH BECAUSE.
GLOBAL WARMING IS BY DEFINITION
A GLOBAL PROBLEM BUT ALSO
BECAUSE WE WILL BENEFIT IN
CALIFORNIA BOTH ENVIRONMENTALLY
AND ECONOMICALLY TO THE EXTENT
THAT OUR MEASURES. ARE COPIED BY
OTHERS.
SO IN ADDITION TO REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SEVERAL
STRATEGIES IN THE SCOPING PLAN
WERE DEVELOPED AS PART OF OUR
EFFORTS TO MEET FEDERAL AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS. AND REDUCE
TOXICS AS WELL SO THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD AND RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD AYE
DELIVERING CLEANER FUELS AND
ENERGY THE ADVANCE CLEAN CARS
PROGRAM. WHICH IS PUT MORE THAN
A QUARTER MILLION CLEAN VEHICLES
ON THE ROAD AND THE STATE OF
AFRAID ACTION PLAN WILL RESULT
IN EFFICIENT AND CLEANER SYSTEMS
TO MOVE GOODS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WE BELIEVE THAT A CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AS PART OF A PACKAGE
WITH OTHER REDUCTION MEASURES.
IS ESSENTIAL BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
US TO MEET OUR S. B. THIRTY TWO
GOALS WITH THE HIGHEST DEGREE OF
CERTAINTY AND LOWEST COST
AVAILABLE. IT ALSO PROVIDES
FURTHER BENEFITS INCLUDING
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS OF THE AT
DIRECT INVESTMENTS OF CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND UNDERSCORES
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUED NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL LEADERSHIP ON
CLIMATE.
CAP AND TRADE PROVIDES AND
EFFICIENT AND SUSTAIN MARKET
SIGNAL TO INVEST IN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROMOTING A SHIFT TO
CLEANER FORMS OF ENERGY
THROUGHOUT OUR ECONOMY.
INDEED OUR MODELING SHOWS THAT
THE COST OF OTHER REGULATORY
OPTIONS IS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
HIGHER TO ACHIEVE THE SAME
TARGET FOR ANY GIVEN TARGET. SO
WE THINK THAT ARE MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH TO REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IS MORE EFFECTIVE
WITH CAP AND TRADE THEM WITHOUT
IT. AND WE'RE VERY GRATIFIED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN
US DIRECTION TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE PROGRAM WITH SOME.
ADDITIONAL ARE PROTECTIONS IN
AT.
WITH THE DECLINING EMISSIONS CAP
THIS PROGRAM IS LEADING TO REEL
IN THE STATE REDUCTIONS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES AS WELL AS
OTHER POLLUTANTS. THERE'S
UNDERSTANDABLE CONCERN THAT NOT
ALL FACILITIES ARE REDUCING
EMISSIONS EQUALLY UNDER THE CAP.
IN ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT THIS
ACTUALLY IS TRUE FOR ALL
REGULATORY PROGRAMS NOT JUST CAP
AND TRADE. FOR EXAMPLE AS PART
OF OUR LONGSTANDING CRITERIA
POLLUTANT PROGRAMS AIR DISTRICTS
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING
RULES AND PERMITS TO LIMIT
EMISSIONS FROM EQUIPMENT AT NEW
AND EXISTING INDUSTRIAL SOURCES.
EACH INDIVIDUAL AIR DISTRICTS
PROGRAMS REFLECT THE NATURE AND
SEVERITY OF THE AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THEIR REGION AND
LOCAL PREFERENCES ABOUT HOW TO
ADDRESS THOSE. CHALLENGES.
DISTRICT RULES AND PERMITS
ESTABLISH EMISSIONS LIMITS BUT
THEY ALSO CONSIDER FEASIBILITY
AND COST EFFECTIVENESS WHICH
ACCOMMODATE DIFFERENCES AMONG
INDIVIDUAL FACILITIES.
BECAUSE OF THIS EMISSIONS MAY
VARY FROM FACILITY TO FACILITY
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE IN THE SAME
BUSINESS AND SUBJECT TO THE SAME
REGULATION. THIS IS NO DIFFERENT
THAN THE WAY CAP AND TRADE WORKS
TO ENSURE OVERALL COST EFFECTIVE
REDUCTIONS BY ACCOMMODATING
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE
FACILITIES.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT TO
ADDRESS EMISSIONS DISPARITIES
WITHIN COMMUNITIES AND AMONG
COMMUNITIES. WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE REGULATORY SYSTEMS AS A
WHOLE THE WHOLE SCOPING PLANT
AND ITS ASSOCIATED STRATEGIES
INCLUDING CAP AND TRADE. AND THE
LOCAL RULEMAKING AND PERMITTING
PROCESSES THAT ARE USED TO
ADDRESS CRITERIA AND TOXICS
EMISSIONS. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT FRANKLY HAS NEVER BEEN DONE
ANYWHERE BEFORE. THAT IS WHY AB
ONE NINETY SEVEN AND AB SIX
SEVENTEEN ARE SO IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE A NEW
FRAMEWORK THAT ALONG WITH
EXISTING LAWS FOCUSES ON
EMISSIONS DISPARITIES OF
CRITERIA AND TOXIC POLLUTANTS
THAT HAVE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
FOR DECADES.
YOUR HANDOUTS CHAU ARE ALSO SHOW
A GRAPH OF THE INVENTORY TREND
AND A GRAPH THAT SHOWS HOW
CALIFORNIA'S REDUCED GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. RELATIVE TO GROSS
DOMESTIC PRODUCT AND PER CAPITA
OVER TIME.
TO PROVIDE A CONTEXT FOR THIS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOR STATEWIDE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS HAVE
DECREASED BY FIFTY MILLION
METRIC TONS CO TWO EQUIVALENT OR
ABOUT TEN PERCENT.
WHICH WOULD BE THE EQUIVALENT OF
REMOVING APPROXIMATELY TEN AND A
HALF MILLION PASSENGER VEHICLES
FROM THE ROSE. THAT'S THAT
CURRENTLY THAT CURRENT EMISSIONS
LEVELS THAT THE X. VEHICLES
EXCUSING.
YOU CAN SEE.
HOW THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION IMPACTED EMISSIONS AS
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY DECREASED?
BUT AS OUR ECONOMY REBOUNDED
AFTER THE RECESSION IT IT DID SO
WITH A MUCH LOWER CARBON
FOOTPRINT.
SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY DECOUPLED
GROWTH IN THE ECONOMY FROM
GROWTH IN EMISSIONS OF CO TWO.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MAKE THAT POINT BECAUSE MANY
PEOPLE ASSUMED THAT REDUCED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY MUST ACCOMPANY
REDUCE GHG.
EMISSIONS
OUR EXPERIENCE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS HAS SHOWN THAT THAT IS
FALSE.
CALIFORNIA'S DEMONSTRATING TO
THE WORLD THAT YOU CAN DECOUPLE
GHG EMISSIONS AND ECONOMIC
GROWTH.
LAST WE'RE ON TRACK TO MEET OUR
AB THIRTY TWO GHG TARGETS OF
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS OF
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY TWENTY. WE
BELIEVE WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO
ACHIEVE THE TWENTY TWENTY TARGET
STANDARD SOMEWHAT BEFORE TWENTY
TWENTY AND THAT'S A VERY GOOD
THING. IT PUTS US ON A PATH FOR
THE NEXT DECADE WHERE WE WILL
NEED EVEN STEEPER REDUCTIONS.
SO WHILE THIS NEW PLAN IS SET
TO.
ON A PATH TO ACHIEVE A TWENTY
THIRTY TARGET. THERE ARE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO FINE TUNE THIS
PLAN.
ONE A YEAR AS AYE REPORT TO THIS
COMMITTEE AS REQUIRED ON OUR
PROGRESS AND WE ALSO PROVIDE
WRITTEN REPORTS ON OUR CLIMATE
CHANGE PROGRAMS. YOU WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY IN A FORMAL WAY
TO HEAR WHAT CHANGES WERE
CONTEMPLATING AND TO GIVE US
YOUR.
VIEWS IN ADDITION TO OTHER WAYS
IN WHICH.
YOU OF COURSE HAVE INPUT TO OUR
WORK AS WELL.
R. BOARD RECEIVES ANNUAL
BRIEFINGS ON IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SCOPING PLAN AND A B. THIRTY
TWO REQUIRES US TO UPDATE THE
PLAN EVERY FIVE YEARS. SO ACTIVE
WORST CASE EVERY FIVE YEARS WE
WOULD BE PRODUCING A NEW PLAN.
THAT UPDATES BASED ON NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND AN ASSESSMENT
OF WHERE WE ARE.
AS WITH ALL OF OUR PLANS AND
REGULATIONS WILL BE MONITORING
IMPLEMENTATION AND CONTINUING TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL. AS LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO ADJUST COURSE OR
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS AS NEEDED.
THERE'S A HANDOUT ALSO THAT
LISTS ALL OF THE REPORTING AND
OVERSIGHT OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENGAGE ON THE CLIMATE PROGRAMS
AND I THINK IT'S.
AYE MAY BE HELPFUL TO JUST SEE
THAT ARRAY OF. DIFFERENT
INTERACTIONS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT PROVIDED
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION FOR THE
FUTURE OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM INCLUDING THE CAPS
ADDING USE OF OFFSETS PRICE
CONTAINMENT POINTS. AND THE
PRICE CEILING WE HAVE HEARD THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALSO FOR MANY
OTHERS WHO WANT TO WEIGH IN ON
HOW WE SHOULD INCORPORATE THESE
CHANGES INTO THE REGULATIONS.
AND I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT WE
ARE NOW IN THE MIDST OF A FULL
PUBLIC PROCESS THAT WILL
EVALUATE AND CONSIDER ALL THE
SUGGESTIONS. I KNOW THAT THE LA
I WAS SPEAKING AFTER ME AND WILL
WANT TO DISCUSS SOME OF THESE
AREAS IN MORE DETAIL. I JUST
WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT WE HAVE
NOT REACHED OUR FINAL
CONCLUSIONS ON HOW ANY OF THIS
WILL BE PUT FORWARD AND THAT WE
ARE UP PAYING ATTENTION TO TO
WHAT WE HEAR.
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE'RE
GONNA DO SHARE OUR PROPOSALS
PUBLICLY IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
ALL MARKET PARTICIPATES AND
INTERESTED PARTIES. GET THE SAME
INFORMATION AT THE SAME TIME AND
I MAKE THIS UP POINT BECAUSE WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING AS WE SPEAK A
MARKET BASED PROGRAM WHERE
THERE'S TRADING GOING ON. IN
CALIFORNIA CARBON ALLOWANCES AND
AS WITH ANY TYPE OF A MARKET
TRADING PROGRAM AT INSIDER
INFORMATION HAS VALUE AND CAN
DISTORT THE PROGRAM AND SO WE'RE
VERY VERY CAREFUL WHEN WE DO
RELEASE INFORMATION. THAT WE
RELEASED IT IN PUBLIC AT THE
SAME TIME TO EVERYBODY WHO MIGHT
HAVE AN INTEREST IN IT.
SO LOOKING FORWARD TO WHAT OUR
CHALLENGES ARE. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SHARE WITH YOU DOES
THAT ONE SECTOR REALLY STANDS
OUT AS THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF
EMISSIONS AND OUR STATE AND THAT
IS THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. IT
ACCOUNTS FOR APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
PERCENT OF ALL THE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS NINETY PERCENT OF
DIESEL PARTICULATE AS I SAID
BEFORE. LARGEST EMISSIONS
SOURCES INCLUDING TRUCKS
LOCOMOTIVES AND SHIPS
WHICH ARE IN SOME CASES NOT
SUBJECT TO DIRECT CONTROL BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THEY'RE UNDER NATIONAL OR
INTERNATIONAL.
CONTROL OUT BUT WE CAN'T MEET
OUR EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS GOALS
WITHOUT SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTIONS
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
OUR APPROACH IN THIS SECTOR
INCLUDES NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
FINDING WAYS TO BRING THEM ON
FUELS INCENTIVES INSISTING OF
WILL LAND USE PLANNING. BUT A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR SUCCESS
DEPENDS ON SUPPORT FROM THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTIVELY AT
WORK DISMANTLING THE FEDERAL
RESPONSE TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CLEAN AIR. BETWEEN DISBANDING
THE FEDERAL CLIMATE ADVISORY
PANEL PREPARING TO RESCIND THE
CLEAN POWER PLAN COURT ACTIONS
ROLLING BACK FEDERAL LAWS AND
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES. AND
WITHDRAWING FROM THE PARIS
CLIMATE AGREEMENT. EVERY MONTH
BRINGS ANOTHER ROLLBACK AND
INCREASINGLY ALARMING POLICIES
THAT REALLY ARE THREATENED THAT
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE. TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND OUR
CLIMATE.
CALIFORNIA HAS CONTINUED AND I
BELIEVE I SPEAK FOR ALL OF US
WHEN I SAY THAT. I EXPECT THAT
WE WILLCONTINUE TO AT LEAD THE
WAY NOT ONLY BY PROVIDING AN
EXAMPLE OF REDUCING EMISSIONS
WHILE GROWING OUR ECONOMY. BUT
ALSO AS A PLACE THAT DRIVES NEW
pTECHNOLOGY INNOVATIONS.
STATE THAT LOOKS BEYOND OUR
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION AND
DECADES INTO THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER FEDERAL ACTIONS OR LACK
THEREOF MAY NOT ONLY IN PERIL
LOT ACTIONS THAT ARE TAKEN IN
OTHER STATES BUT ALSO MAY
UNDERCUT OUR ABILITY AS A STATE.
WE ARE UNIQUE IN THE COUNTRY AND
BEING ABLE TO ADOPT MORE
STRINGENT MOTOR VEHICLE
EMISSIONS AS A STATE. BASED ON
THE HISTORY OF OUR EARLY
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP AND OUR
ON GOING AIR QUALITY CHALLENGES.
HOWEVER IN ORDER TO ADOPT NEW
STANDARDS EVERY TIME WE LOOK AT
A PROGRAM.
WE HAVE TO SEEK A WAIVER FROM
U. S. EPA. THIS PROCESS HAS
GROWN TO INCLUDE OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS STANDARDS ALSO
KNOWN AS THE PAVLEY REGULATIONS.
AND OF COURSE WE'VE USED THIS
PROCESS TO.
ATTRACT OTHER STATES THAT WANT
TO FOLLOW OUR LEAD WHICH THEY
CONTINUE TO DO.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO SEEK A
PRODUCTIVE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE VEHICLE EMISSION
STANDARDS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION MAY CHOOSE NOT TO
APPROVE R. WAIVERS. TO PURSUE
FUTURE STANDARDS OR EVEN ATTEMPT
TO ATTACK OUR AUTHORITY
ALTOGETHER.
AND I I WANT TO END ON THIS NOTE
OF ALARM BECAUSE.
IF WE WERE TO LOSE THE ABILITY
TO SET GREENHOUSE GAS STANDARDS
FOR VEHICLES. WE WOULD CERTAINLY
FIGHT.
WE WOULD FIGHT IT WITH EVERY
LEGAL TOOL THAT WAS AVAILABLE TO
US AS WELL AS. ALL OTHER TOOLS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN THE COURT
OF PUBLIC OPINION.
BUT IF WE WERE TO LOSE WE WOULD
REALLY LOSE SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE. ALL OF THE VARIOUS.
OBJECTIVES THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY. OUR
ABILITY TO REDUCE MOBILE SOURCE
EMISSIONS INCLUDING GREENHOUSE
GASES AND CRITERIA AND TOXICS
WOULD BE HUGELY IMPAIRED NOT TO
MENTION THE NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT
THIS WOULD HAVE ON THE HEALTH.
OF NEARBY COMMUNITIES AND IF WE
WERE TO TRY TO CONTINUE TO.
TO ACHIEVE OUR OVERALL GOALS WE
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE UP THE
REMAINING REDUCTIONS THROUGH
ALTERNATIVE MEASURES THAT WOULD
BE DIRECTED AT OTHER SECTORS AS
AS NECESSARY SO. WITH THAT.
I WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY I'M
SORRY THAT THIS HAS BEEN A LONG
BUT I THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO LAY OUT THE.
OVERALL AND SITUATION IN
RESPONSE TO THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE WERE AND ASKED IN ADVANCE AND
I AM GOING TO BE VERY HAPPY TO
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS. THAT THANK
YOU A COLLEAGUES UNLESS THERE'S
A BURNING QUESTION THAT WE WANT
TO ASK NOW IS IT OKAY IF. WE GO
INTO THE NEXT PRESENTER. AND
THEN OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
AND AND. COMMENTS.
CONSENSUS IS OKAY YEP THEN WILL.
YEAH SHE'S GOT SHE'S I THINK
ISRAEL YEAH.
ALRIGHT CLEARLY BECAUSE CAP AND
TRADE
AS OF REFERENCE GONNA PLAYS A
KEY ROLE AND.
TWENTY.
THIRTY SCOPING PLAN THAT WAS
RECENTLY ADOPTED BY CAR.
AS SORT OF THE WAY TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE MEETS ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS TARGETS AND SO WE
WANT TO KIND OF FOCUS ON SOME
THE KEY IMPLEMENTATION DECISIONS
THAT COULD THAT COULD AFFECT.
AND THE ABILITY OF THE PROGRAM
TO HELP ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
I WILL JUST MAKE JUST THAT
BEFORE I CAN GET INTO SOME OF
THOSE KEY IMPLEMENTATION
DECISIONS THAT WE HIGHLIGHTED
AND OVERSIGHT ISSUES THAT WE
HIGHLIGHTED.
DO JUST WANT TO KIND OF. MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT ON JUST GENERAL
KIND OF.
AND ISSUES RELATED TO THE
SCOPING PLAN.
.
THE SCOPING PLAN INCLUDES A
VARIETY OF POLICIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY DIRECTED
AGENCIES TO IMPLEMENT SUCH AS AN
RP ASSN VARIOUS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER THERE'S ALSO A FAIR
AMOUNT OF DISCRETION FOR CARP TO
ADOPTS ADDITIONAL POLICIES THAT
IT FEELS IT AND ARE NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE
GAS GOALS AND POLICIES. WHILE
THERE'S SOME.
DIRECTION IN STATUTE.
FOR A RB TO CONSIDER THINGS
LIKE COST EFFECTIVENESS.
.
TECHNOLOGICAL FEASIBILITY.
PIMCO POLLUTANTS LEAKAGE IN A
VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS.
ULTIMATELY THERE'D THAT COMES
DOWN TO KIND OF.
DELICATE BALANCE A BALANCE IN
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT FACTORS AND
SO I SINCE THERE'S A FAIR AMOUNT
OF DISCRETION GIVEN TO CAR WE
THINK THESE TYPES OF OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS TO. CHECK IN ON KIND OF
HOW CARP HAS BALLOTS THOSE
DIFFERENT THINGS AND PUTTING THE
PLAN TOGETHER ARE PARTICULARLY.
HELPFUL.
.
AND ARE BE ONE KEY ISSUE TO.
IN PARTICULAR TO KEEP AN EYE ON
IS IS COST EFFECTIVENESS
EFFECTIVENESS IN THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH A DIFFERENT
POLICIES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE PLAN.
THOSE COSTS ARE ARE ULTIMATELY
BORNE BY.
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES.
.
AND SO WE THINK SOME IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT WANT TO CONTINUE TO ASK IN
THIS HEARING AND OTHERS IS.
TO THE EXTENT OF POLICIES
ADOPTED THAT IT'S ESTIMATED TO
BE MORE COSTLY THEN ALTERNATIVE
WHAT ARE THE REASONS FOR
ADOPTING THAT POLICY WIRES.
POTENTIALLY MORE COSTLY POLICY
BEING ADOPTED ARE THERE MAY BE
VERY GOOD REASONS FOR DOING THAT
PERHAPS THERE'S NEEDS TO BE SOME
SORT OF TECHNOLOGICAL PUSH OR
THERE ARE OTHER TYPES OF
POLLUTANTS THAT ARE TRYING TO BE
ADDRESSED FOR THAT POLICY BUT.
TO TRY TO GET GOOD INFORMATION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS MIGHT BE WORTH.
WHATEVER ADDITIONAL BENEFITS
MIGHT COME WITHOUT POLICY.
THAT ALSO.
PERHAPS ASKING THE QUESTION ARE
THERE OTHER POLICY TOOLS ARE
AVENUES THAT COULD BE USED TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE OTHER.
GOALS THAT ARE TRYING TO THAT
SHOULDN'T TRYING TO BE ACHIEVED
OUTSIDE OF GREENHOUSE GASES AND
I THINK AB SIX SEVENTEEN IT'S
GOT ANOTHER IS AN EXAMPLE OF.
KIND OF AN APPROACH TO TRYING
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
THROUGH SORT OF DIFFERENT A
POLICY VENUE THAN THAN THE SCOPE
AND.
THE OTHER KEY ISSUE.
WE WANNA HIGHLIGHT IS JUST KIND
OF THE. THE QUESTIONS AROUND.
THE RISK AND THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE PLAN AS OUTLINED.
BY CAR BUT IS GOING TO ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE.
CAP AND TRADE IS REALLY SORT
CENTRAL IN THE PLAN AS A
BACKSTOP.
TWO IF YOU KNOW OTHER POLICIES
EITHER DON'T WORK OR JUST MAKE
UP THE DIFFERENCE AND THE
ADDITIONAL EMISSION REDUCTIONS
THAT ARE NEEDED THAT OTHER
POLICIES ARE.
ACHIEVING THE CABIN TRADERS
THERE. TO KIND OF HELP ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS AND HELP ME THE
STATE TARGETS.
AND I THINK THE KEY QUESTION
THAT WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE TO ASK IS IS A PROGRAM
UP TO THAT SHOT IS A DESIGNED IN
A WAY.
THAT WILL ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS AND THIS GETS INTO SOME OF
THE DETAILS AROUND KIND OF THE
SPECIFIC DESIGN ELEMENTS AND
STRUCTURE OF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. THAT WE.
DISCUSS IN OUR REPORT SO. I
WANTED TO JUST TOUCH ON TWO OF
THOSE ISSUES THERE'S WE TALK
ABOUT A VARIETY OF ISSUES IN OUR
REPORT BUT I WANNA TOUCH ON. TWO
OF THEM IS AS IMPORTANT KIND OF
QUESTIONS AND THINGS THAT THINK
ABOUT AS FAR AS RISKS OF NOT
MEETING THE. THE.
THE STATE'S TWENTY THIRTY GOALS
AND ANYTHING ABOUT DESIGN
FEATURES THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM.
THE FIRST RELATES TO.
BANKING AND SETTING THE POST
TWENTY TWENTY CAPS
SO THIS REAL QUICKLY BANKING AS
THAT IS A DESIGN FEATURE IN THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM WHERE AN
ALLOWANCE ISSUED TODAY. CAN BE
USED TO.
HELD OUT A PURCHASED IN HELD
ONTO AND USED IN A FUTURE YOU'RE
IN THE PROGRAM.
AND IT'S REALLY KIND OF.
.
SET UP AS SORT OF A WAY TO KIND
OF.
AND MITIGATE PRICE VOLATILITY
BASICALLY WRITTEN OFF THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION AS THE KAPPA COMES
MORE STRINGENT OVER TIME PRICES
IN LATER YEARS COULD BE QUITE A
BIT HIGHER FOR ALLOWANCES THAN
THEY ARE TODAY AND SO THAT.
CREATES AN INCENTIVE TO.
PURCHASED OR OBTAINED SOME
ALLOWANCES NOW AND SO THAT HAS
THE EFFECT OF KIND OF.
SMOOTHING PRICES OVER TIME
ESSENTIALLY CAN I THINK
POTENTIALLY INCREASING PRICES IN
THE NEAR TERM BUT LOWERING
PRICES.
IN THE OUT YEARS AND SO IT AND
ALSO HAS OR HAS THE EFFECT OF
MOVING. EMISSIONS AN EMISSION
REDUCTIONS.
FROM ONE TIME PERIOD TO THE
OTHER TIME PERIOD.
THERE'S A LOT OF BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH AND I HAVE BEEN
BANKING AS PART OF THE PROGRAM
REDUCING PRICE VOLATILITY
ENCOURAGING. EARLIER A MISSION
REDUCTIONS IN THOSE ARE.
WE THINK SIGNIFICANT ADVANTAGES
TO HAVING THAT AS PART OF THE
PROGRAM. OUT WE JUST WENT OUT
HIGHLIGHT ONE TRADE OFF
ASSOCIATED WITH DOING THAT BY BY
HAVING.
BANKING ALLOWED IN THE PROGRAM
ESSENTIALLY CREATES A KIND OF
CUMULATIVE CAP OVER MANY
DIFFERENT YEARS OF THE PROGRAM
SO IT'S NOT. AN ANNUAL CAP ON
EMISSIONS.
IT'S REALLY KIND OF SINCE YOU
CAN MOVE THOSE ALLOW ALLOWANCES
FROM EARLY YEARS TO LATER YEARS
THAT THEY CAME OUT OF CAP ON
EMISSIONS AND. THAT JUST CREATES
A KIND OF FUNDAMENTAL TENSION
BETWEEN. OF HAVING THAT ASPECT
OF THE PROGRAM AND HAVING A
TWENTY THIRTY ANNUAL TARGET IN
PLACE AND SO WE JUST KIND OF
WANNA. HIGHLIGHT THAT AS ONE
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO TO THINK
ABOUT WHEN THINKING ABOUT THE
CERTAINTY ANY CERTAINTY THAT
HAPPENED TRADE. PROVIDES IS
GOING TO PROVIDE SECULAR
ADMONITION CERTAINTY BUT NOT
NECESSARILY AS MUCH. ANNUAL
EMISSIONS CERTAINTY.
BECAUSE YOU CAN USE SOME BANK
ALLOWANCES FROM EARLIER YEARS
AND LATER YEARS.
THE ISSUE IS THAT COULD BE
PARTICULARLY SIGNIFICANT F.
THERE'S A LARGE NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES THAT CAN BE BANKS
FROM EARLIER YEARS AND USED IN
LATER YEARS. AND YOU YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY RESULT IN A
SITUATION WHERE IN THE LATER
YEARS OF A LARGE NUMBER OF BANK
ALLOWANCES ARE USED YOU'RE SICK
YOU ARE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN WHAT YOUR ACTUAL TWENTY
THIRTY ANNUAL TARGET DOES.
I I'D LIKE TO POINT YOU TO A
PAGE AIDS OF OUR REPORT IN
FIGURE THREE.
AND I THINK THIS IS REALLY OUR
ATTEMPTS TO PROVIDE AN EXAMPLE
ILLUSTRATION OF JUST SOME OF THE
ISSUES I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
.
JUST TOOK A WALK YOU THROUGH
FIGURE THREE ON PAGE EIGHT.
YOU SEE THE THE TOP AND A LIGHT
PURPLE LINE THERE IS REALLY.
WHAT THE ANNUAL CAPS ARE THE NOT
BASICALLY THE NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES THAT ARE ISSUED IN
THE PROGRAM AND YOU'LL SEE THAT
KIND OF? RELATIVELY STEEP
DECLINE IN THE ANNUAL CAPS FROM.
TWENTY FIFTEEN DOWN TO TWENTY
THIRTY REACHING THAT THE TWENTY
THIRTY ANNUAL TARGET.
NOW THAT THE REDLINE THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT BELOW THAT IN THIS
LITTLE LESS DEEP THAN THAT
PURPLE LINE. IS KIND OF THOSE
FIRST COUPLE YEARS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN IS WHERE
EMISSIONS OF ACTUALLY. BAN SO
YOU CAN SEE AN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN EMISSIONS
HAVE BEEN BELOW WHERE THOSE
ANNUAL CAPS HAVE BEEN.
AND THIS EXAMPLE IN THIS CHART
WE JUST PROVIDE AN EXAMPLE
SCENARIO WHERE EMISSIONS
CONTINUE TO DECLINE BUT I.
YOU KNOW AT A RELATIVELY STEADY
RATE AND NOT AS STEEP AS THAT
THE COPS ACTUAL ACTUALLY DECLINE
AND SO IN THIS TYPE OF SCENARIO
YOU COULD.
RESULTS
AND A LARGE NUMBER OF BANKS
ALLOWANCES FROM SO THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT THE
PURPLE LINE AND THAT THE RED
LINE.
THOSE ARE KIND OF HELD ONTO NOT
USED IN THOSE EARLIER YEARS OF
THE PROGRAM AND THEN USE TO
COMPLY AND THE LATER YEARS OF
THE PROGRAM. AND SO IF YOU YOU
SORT OF SEE THE RIGHT HAND SIDE
OF THE CHART THERE AS HE REACHED
THE LATER YEARS OF THE PROGRAM
OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY.
YOU GET OUT A SCENARIO WHERE
THE ACTUAL EMISSIONS ALTHOUGH
THE CAPS ARE SET LOWER AND I CAN
SET TO REACH THE TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET. ACTUAL EMISSIONS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN THAT
AND SO THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
EXAMPLES THIS IS THIS IS ONE
EXAMPLE THAT COULD BE MANY
POTENTIAL.
FUTURE SCENARIOS BUT THE TYPE
OF EXAMPLE WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND CARVE SHOULD BE.
THINKING ABOUT AND THINKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
CERTAINTY DOES NOT A CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED PROVIDED MEDIAN THE
THE STATE'S TWENTY THIRTY GOALS.
I EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT DOES
PROVIDE DIRECTION TO CARB TO.
TO ANALYZE THIS ISSUE AND SO WE
THINK.
TO GO IMPORTANT FILED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE CAN TO TO CONTINUE
TO ASK.
HOW CARBS ANALYZING THIS ISSUE
WHAT CRITERIA THAT'S GOING TO
USE TO DETERMINE WHETHER OUT OF
THINKS IT'S A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
AND IF SO IF IT IS DETERMINED TO
BE A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE? WHAT
TYPES OF RESPONSES THE STATE
MIGHT TAKE TO ADDRESS THIS
POTENTIAL RISK IN NOT MEETING
THE THE TWENTY THIRTY GOALS ARM?
AND OUR OUR REPORT WE HIGHLIGHT
ONE POTENTIAL OPTION.
IF THIS IS DETERMINED TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT RISK OF NOT MEETING
OUR OUR OF THE LONG TERM TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS.
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW ADJUSTING
POST TWENTY TWENTY CAPS TO ANNE
OF DOWNWARD ESSENTIALLY.
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES SOLD AT REGULAR
OPTIONS GOING FORWARD A TO KINDA
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THERE'S
A.
IF THERE IS AN ISSUE THERE'S A
A RISK ERA TRADE OFF I GUESS
ASSOCIATE WITH DOING THAT BY
REDUCING THE SUPPLY OF
ALLOWANCES THAT PUTS UPWARD
PRESSURE ON. PRICES AND COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROGRAM. AND
THAT SAID YOU WERE OUT THERE ARE
A VARIETY OF OTHER AYE DESIGN
FEATURES IN THE CABIN FOR A
PROGRAM LIKE A HARD PRICE
CEILING LIKE VARIOUS PRICE
CONTAINMENT POINTS THAT ARE.
SPECIFICALLY SET OUT TO TRY AND
MITIGATE ANY CONCERNS ABOUT.
HIGH PRICES IN AND PRICE
INCREASES AND SO I WOULD THINK
THAT THE STATE IN THE
LEGISLATION OUT OF THINK ABOUT
RELYING ON THOSE ARE SORT OF THE
THE TOOL TO MITIGATE AGAINST
POTENTIAL. PRICE INCREASES.
NOW THE SECOND FEATURE I'LL JUST
TOUCH ON VERY BRIEFLY.
AND AS WAS REFERENCED IN THE
OPENING COMMENTS R. EIGHTY THREE
NINETY EIGHT ALSO DIRECTED CARB
TO ESTABLISH A HARD PRICE
CEILING.
AND.
ESSENTIALLY AN EFFORT TO HELP.
LIMIT POTENTIAL HIGH COSTS AND
HIGHER ALLOWANCE PRICES IN THE
PROGRAM.
THIS IS IMPLEMENTED.
ESSENTIALLY BY.
ONCE PRICES REACHED THAT THE
LEVEL OF THAT HARD PRICE CEILING
THEN CARVE WILL.
ISSUE OR SAU ALLOWANCES AT THAT
PRICE ESSENTIALLY AN UNLIMITED
NUMBER ALLOWANCES AT THAT PRICE
SO WHILE THIS DESIGN FEATURE
DOES HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
CONTAINING COSTS THERE. CLEAR
TRADE OFF IS THAT IF PRICES
REACHED THAT LEVEL THEN THERE'S
NO LONGER THE SAME TYPE OF CAP
ON EMISSIONS AND. AND CAR WILL.
WILL ISSUE COMPLIANCE
INSTRUMENTS UNLIMITED EMERALD
COMPLIANCE INSTRUMENTS AT THAT
PARTICULAR PRICE.
THAT THE LEGISLATION GIVES CAR
SO THIS IS THE AYE AYE ANOTHER
AREA OF KIND OF RISK UNCERTAINTY
AROUND SEE OF THE STATE. THE
CAPTAIN OF ENSURING THAT THE
STATE NEEDS ITS CLIMATE GOALS
AND ARGUED THAT IT'S A
REASONABLE.
POLICY. A DESIGN FEATURE BUT IT
IT IS IT IS A RISK.
.
THE LEGISLATION AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT GETS CAR BUT.
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION IN
DETERMINING THE LEVEL OF THIS
PRICE CEILING SO HAVE HOW TO
BALANCE THAT COST CONTAINMENT
FEATURE AND. THE POTENTIAL OF OF
ISSUING MORE ALLOWANCES AND
POTENTIALLY EXCEEDING WHAT THE
THE OVERALL CAPPERS. SO THAT'S
AGAIN A VERY.
AND ARGUE IMPORTANT AREA FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE OVERSIGHT ON.
WHAT THEIR CAR BAND ITS PROPOSED
PRICE CEILING?
BALANCES THESE CONCERNS AROUND
COSTS AS WELL AS EMISSIONS
CERTAINTY IN A WAY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE.
AGREES WITH THINGS CONSISTENT
WITH ITS PRIORITIES.
FINALLY I I JUST TOUCH VERY
QUICKLY ON JUST ONE OTHER ISSUE
WE RAISED IN THE REPORT AND THAT
RELATES TO JUST ONGOING
OVERSIGHT.
STATE KIND OF POLICIES AND CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. I AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT CREATED.
A NEW INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS
MARKET ADVISORY COMMITTEES TO
HELP ASSESS AND LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT.
AND ADVISE ON ON DIFFERENT
POLICIES.
THAT.
COMMITTEE IS TASKED WITH
EVALUATING THE FIREMEN ON
ECONOMIC PERFORMANCE OF CAP AND
TRADE AND OTHER RELATED CLIMATE
POLICIES.
AND AS THE TO CONSIST OF
EXPERTS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUR OFFICE.
AND ARMY WE THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF VALUE IN HELPING THE
LEGISLATURE I GET BETTER
INFORMATION ON THE EFFECTS OF
ITS KIND OF POLICIES.
THAT HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
EXPERTISE GONNA HELP IN.
WITH LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
EFFORTS.
WE ALSO BUT WE DO WANT TO POINT
OUT SOME POTENTIAL AREAS WERE
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANNA
THINK ABOUT CLARIFYING OR
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DIRECTION
ABOUT THE ROLE OF THE COMMITTEE.
ONE EXAMPLE IS JUST THE SCOPE
OF ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE
COMMITTEE.
.
THE A LEGISLATION REFERENCES CAP
AND TRADE AND OTHER RELATED
CLIMATE POLICIES AND SO.
IF THE COMMITTEE IS TASKED WITH
EVALUATING ALL THE DIFFERENT
CLIMATE POLICIES THAT THE STATE
HAS AYE THAT COULD EITHER
REQUIRE A LOT OF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
OR.
PERHAPS LIMIT SORT OF THE THEIR
ABILITY TO KIND OF DIG DEEPLY
INTO ONE PARTICULAR KIND OF
POLICY LIKE CAP AND TRADE.
THE OTHER ISSUE IS JUST ADD
MORE ABOUT THE KIND OF THE ROLE
OF THE COMMITTEE AND WHAT TYPE
OF INFORMATION THE LEGISLATURE
WANTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S CALL ITS NAME AND ADVISORY
COMMITTEE BUT THE STATUTE
RELEASE ARE DIRECTED TO EVALUATE
THE.
THE AFFECTS OF PROGRAMS AND SO
IN SOME WAYS
AND A VAST SERVING AS AN
ADVISORY ROLE IS THAT OFTENTIMES
VERY DIFFERENT FROM OF VALUE IT
IN PERFORMANCE OF THE PROGRAM
AND ANALYZING AND EVALUATING
PAST PERFORMANCE OF THE PROGRAM
AND SO. OF THE LEGISLATURE.
MIGHT WANNA THINK ABOUT. THAT
CLEAR FINE YOU KNOW WHICH OF
THOSE EXACTLY.
WHICH ROLE IT WOULD LIKE THE
COMMITTEE TO UNDERTAKE I KNOW
CARBON AT AN INITIAL WORKSHOP
HAS INDICATED THAT.
.
IT VIEWS AS YOU THE COMMITTEE AS
HAVING A ROLE IN EVALUATING
PASSED PROGRAM PERFORMANCE BUT
NOT NECESSARILY ADVISING ON THE
FUTURE DESIGN. A OF THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM RATHER CLIMATE
POLICIES AND SO ON THE
LEGISLATURE WILL I THINK WHEN I
LOOK AT AT WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT ITS INTENT
WAS. AND ARE MOVING FORWARD
WHETHER ONCE THIS COMMITTEE TO
PERFORM THAT FUNCTION OR OR OR
BOTH FUNCTIONS OR DEMOCRATS
STRAIGHT AT ANOTHER COMMITTEE
FOR.
FOR THE.
TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES THAT THAT IT MIGHT
WANT.
SO I WILL.
LEAD MY A KIND OF IN MY
COMMENTS THERE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I'M STILL CYNICAL
FAMOUS R. BROWN.
WE HAVE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR.
GUEST.
MR STERN.
JUMPING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
CHAIR FOR CONVENING TODAY IN
CHAIR NICHOLS AND ROSS FOR
COMING BY ADN YOU'RE WELCOME
BACK.
.
I WANTED TO TOUCH ON THREE QUICK
AREAS AND JUST GET YOUR GUYS
FEEDBACK ON A.
.
IN LIGHT OF THE WILDFIRES WE'VE
BEEN HAVING.
STATEWIDE.
ANOTHER SORT OF UNANTICIPATED
LARGE SCALE EMISSIONS EVENTS
LIKE THE PORTER RANCH GHASTLY.
THREADED ONE END IT GET A SENSE
FROM YOU ALL AS TO THE.
THE INVENTORY ITSELF UNDERLYING
ALL OUR NUMBERS AND HOW.
HOW WE CAN ANTICIPATE THAT
SHIFTING IN FUTURE YEARS HOW WE
CURRENTLY CAPTURE THOSE SORT OF
UNANTICIPATED EMISSIONS AND HOW
THAT? COULD AFFECT OUR PROGRAMS
GOING FOR IT SO TOUCH ON THAT
ONE.
.
THIS THIS QUESTION OF OVERSUPPLY
ALLOWANCES AND ALL THE. THE
ALLOWANCES WE'VE GOT.
SORT OF BANKS IT IN THE PUBLIC
TRUST RIGHT NOW HELD BY THE
AIRPORT.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
BEST TO HANDLE THOSE.
FOR MITIGATING PRICE VOLATILITY
IN THE MARKETS BUT ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT.
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE EXPOSED
TO THIS POLLUTION MOST OF ALL
HAVE SOME INSURANCE HAVE OF
JUSTICE IN THAT.
THEY'RE NOT JUST GONNA BE
EVERYTHING SORT OF LET OUT THE
SYSTEM IN A BUDGET CHEAP
ALLOWANCES FLOODING THE MARKET
NEVER THE AWARENESS OR TO CREATE
A PRICE I SORT OF WANTED TO
HEAR.
STRATEGIES THAT ARE BEING TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT HOW YOU
ALL MIGHT THINK OF ADDRESSING.
THAT AND THEN THE LAST PIECE.
WAS ABOUT.
I APPRECIATE THE DIGGING IN ON
CAP AND TRADE ITSELF AND THAT
SORT OF IN THE CENTERPIECE ALSO
THE SCOPING PLAN BUT.
IT'S MY OPINION THAT IT IS NOT
THE GUARANTOR OF.
NOT ONLY ARE OUR CLIMATE TARGET
ULTIMATELY WE CAN GET THERE ON
CAP AND TRADE BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT WAY FOR THE STATE
TO RELY SOLELY ON THAT I KNOW WE
HAVE GOT ALL THOSE OTHER
COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES IN.
IN OUR PORTFOLIO RIGHT NOW BUT
I'M WORRIED ABOUT TOOLS GETTING
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE SO IF WE
HAVE TO FIGHT THE CLIMATE CHANGE
FIGHT WITH ONE HAND TIED BEHIND
OUR BACK. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LET'S TAKE THAT.
MOBILE SOURCE TO AWAY FROM US
YOU KNOW WHAT OTHER OPTIONS DO
WE HAVE AT OUR DISPOSAL AND
REALLY TO TRY TO GET. A REAL
SENSE FROM YOU WE'RE DEALING
WITH INDUSTRY HERE AT A STATE
LEVEL. AND I FEEL RIGHT NOW LIKE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IS OFFERING INDUSTRY SAY YOU
KNOW WE'VE BEEN SORT OF ON A
GOOD SOLID DIE FOR HOWEVER LONG
NOW CERTAINLY CHANGE YOUR SEEING
AUTO YOU KNOW I WOULDN'T JUST.
PICKED UP A FORD C. MAX.
ONE NINETY NINE A MONTH LEAST
YOU GET A YOU GET YOUR STICKER
YOU GET YOUR REBATE IT'S LIKE
THAT'S THAT'S A CAR A MIDDLE
CLASS FEELINGS ARE TO GET INTO.
THEIR EVEN BETTER YOU FEES ON
THE MARKET RIGHT NOW THINGS ARE
STARTED CHANGING THE AUTO
INDUSTRY.
AND IT SEEMED LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S LISTENING TO THE
AUTO INDUSTRY BECAUSE HE SAVED
A PIECE OF THE TAX CREDIT.
AFTER SOME CEO CALL SO OBVIOUS
IS LISTENING ARE THEY TELLING
WASHINGTON A DIFFERENT STORY
THAN THEY'RE TELLING US.
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE.
YOU KNOW OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CAN OFFER THEM.
THE BACON DOUBLE CHEESEBURGER
AFTER TEN YEARS OF STARTING TO
LIKE CUT SOME OF THAT OUT OF OUR
DIET AND START TO TIGHTEN OUR
BELTS A BIT. MORE DISK INTO
BACKSLIDE WE ARE PROBLEMS SO
JUST.
BUT THAT'S NOT TOO EXPENSIVE BUT
THOSE ARE THE THREE THINGS. WELL
NOT EXPENSIVE AT ALL YEAH.
LEGISLATION AYE I'LL TRY TO
ANSWER ALL THREE QUESTIONS AND
I'LL DO IT THEM FAIRLY BRIEFLY
SO THE FIRST QUESTION IS THAT. I
THINK DIRECTED TO THE ISSUE OF
WHAT'S IN THE INVENTORY AND IN
PARTICULAR.
THE.
.
PROBLEM WHICH WE'VE CERTAINLY
FACED VERY DRAMATICALLY THIS
YEAR THAT AB FIRES CAN RELEASE
LARGE QUANTITIES OF CO TWO AND
ONE THAT'S GOING ON YOU'RE NOT
REALLY SITTING AROUND WORRYING
ABOUT YOUR INVENTORY YOUR
WORRYING ABOUT THE FIRE AND THE
IMPACT ON PEOPLE. ARE WHAT ARE
WE DOING ABOUT THAT SO.
WITH RESPECT TO AND NATURAL
RESOURCES POLICY THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN HAS A LOT
MORE TO SAY ABOUT THAT THAN WE
HAVE IN PREVIOUS SCOPING PLANTS
AND.
WE'RE VERY CLEAR THAT.
THAT OUR NATURAL SYSTEMS NEED
TO BE.
IN BETTER SHAPE BOTH TO
CONSERVE THE CARBON THAT'S
STORED THEY ARE NOW IN OUR LAND
AND AND PLANTS AND AT THE SAME
TIME. TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO OUR
PREVENT.
RELEASES THAT.
IT CAN REALLY I HAVE A. VERY
DRAMATIC EFFECT ON ON GLOBAL
WARMING OVERALL AS DROUGHT
CONTINUES AS WE HAVE.
MORE STRESSES ON OUR ECOSYSTEMS.
THIS IS NOT MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
STRONG ACTION. TO PROTECT OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES IN WAYS THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO PERFORM THE
FUNCTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO
PERFORM IN TERMS OF ABSORBING A
CO TWO FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. OF
THE ARAB STATES AT THROUGH THE
RESOURCES AGENCY HAS DONE A LOT
OF WORK ON OCEANS AND SOME AS
THERE'S A NOW IN THE WORKS AT A
FOREST CARBON PLAN. BUT I THINK
WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
HERE THIS IS ALSO A WORLDWIDE
PROBLEM I KNOW. MENTIONING THE
POSSIBILITY OF YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA PLAYING ANY KIND OF A
ROLE IN PROTECTING FORESTS
ELSEWHERE.
CAUSES A LOT OF PEOPLE TO BE
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE AND THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT WE SHOULD BE
FIRST LOOKING AT OUR OWN.
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT POLICIES
BUT AGAIN IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GLOBAL INVENTORIES WE'VE KNOWN
FOR DECADES NOW THAT YOU CAN
ACHIEVE.
THE THE LEVELS OF LIMITATION ON
EMISSIONS AT THE LEVELS OF HAVE
CONTROL OVER WARMING THAT WE'RE
AIMING FOR WITHOUT INCLUDING AT
NATURAL RESOURCES IN THAT THAT
IS IF WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW OUR.
TROPICAL FORESTS OR OUR
TEMPERATE FORESTS TO BE DEGRADED
OR TO DISAPPEAR WE WON'T MAKE IT
NO MATTER WHAT WE DO WESTCAR SO
WHERE POWER PLANTS OR WHATEVER
SO. THAT'S KIND OF THE THAT THE
BASIC ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
YOUR SECOND QUESTION I THINK
WAS ABOUT.
FEDERAL OVERSUPPLY SO THE
OVERSUPPLY SORRY OVER SPY.
SO ON SHRINKING THE NUMBER OF
ALLOWANCES AS.
AS WAS INDICATED BY MY
COLLEAGUE HERE THERE'S ALWAYS A
TENSION BETWEEN THE DESIRE TO
KEEP PRICES MODERATE AND
PREDICTABLE AND TO MAKE THE
PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTABLE UNDERSTANDABLE.
AND EFFECTIVE AND FREE OF
SCANDALS IN HOW TO DEAL WITH
ISSUES LIKE.
THE POSSIBILITY OF A COMPANY
COMING IN AND BUYING UP A LOT OF
ALLOWANCES SPEAKS THEIR CHEAP
NOW AND THEN IN HOARDING THEM
UNTIL SOME LATER TIME. WE PUT
HOLDING LIMITS IN THE FACT ALL
OF THOSE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE
IN THAT REGARD HAS MADE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MARKET AT.
EXPERTS PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
TRADE IN THE PRIVATE MARKET FOR
OUR ALLOWANCES.
QUITE UNHAPPY BUT BECAUSE IT'S
A MUCH LESS EXCITING MARKET THAT
WAY THE WAY WE IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM LOOKS A LOT MORE LIKE A
REGULATION THAT IT DOES LIKE YOU
KNOW WE ALL COME OUT AND JUST
DAY TRADE ALLOWANCES AS MUCH AS
YOU WANT. WE DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF A PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS DOING ITS JOB IN
TERMS OF REALLY SENDING THE
MESSAGE THAT YOU NEED TO KEEP
INVESTING AND BE INVESTING NOW.
IN THINGS THAT ARE GONNA REDUCE
EMISSIONS OVER THE LONG RUN AS
WE DRIVE TOWARDS TWENTY THIRTY
SO I'M THAT THOSE OF THE COMING
OF QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT. AS WE COME UP WITH OUR
PROPOSALS FOR HOW TO AMEND THE
REGULATION IN RESPONSE TO THE
NEW LEGISLATION OUT AND WE'VE
HEARD FROM. A LOT OF DIFFERENT
FOLKS ABOUT WHAT HOW THEY THINK
WE SHOULD DO IT AT WHERE BLAST
AND I I MEAN THAT SINCERELY BY.
LARGE NUMBERS OF ECONOMISTS AND
OTHER MARKET EXPERTS WHO HAVE
IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO MAKE IT WORK
BETTER AND WE HAVE TO TRY THAT
REALLY LISTEN BUT ALSO THEN.
BAKE SOME MAKE SOME BUT WE'RE
ALSO
CERTAINLY SEEING SIGNS THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT THEY ARE. NOT
INTERESTED IN PURSUING ANY
MEASURES AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THAT WOULD BE.
SUPPORTIVE OF REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GASES.
IN THE WORST CASE SCENARIO.
WHERE THE CLEAN AIR ACT WAS?
UNDER THREAT WAS IT A EPA WHICH
REFUSING TO GRANT WAIVERS TO
CALIFORNIA TO DO OUR. MOTOR
VEHICLE PROGRAMS THERE ARE STILL
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL. BASED ON
STATE LEVEL AUTHORITY.
ZAREPHATH CERTAINLY MEASURES
THAT WE COULD TAKE WHERE.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS FOR FUEL
EFFICIENCY WITH VEHICLES BUT
FUEL EFFICIENCY IN VEHICLES
THINGS LIKE YOU KNOW POLICIES
THAT ARE BEING LOOKED AT AT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND ELSEWHERE
IN TERMS OF.
.
MAKING BUILDINGS ZERO THAT
ENERGY THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT
YOU CAN LOOK AT AS ALTERNATIVES
ON TO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WOULD BE DOING.
MORE DIRECTLY WHERE THINGS WE
CAN DO IN THE AS A STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE AREA OF
LAND USE AND.
PROMOTING.
MORE BICYCLE AND WALKING
FRIENDLY COMMUNITIES IN A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY GOING ON
NOW BUT THAT COULD BE GIVEN
MORE.
EMPHASIS.
AS PART OF STATE PROGRAM THAT
WAS DESIGNED TO TO DEAL WHETHER
A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WASN'T
SUPPORTIVE BUT. I MEAN I THINK
THE. I AM HOPEFUL THAT BECAUSE
THERE ARE MANY OTHER STATES THAT
ARE PURSUING. BOTH FOLLOWING OUR
VEHICLE REGULATIONS AND LOOKING
AT SOME OF OUR OTHER CLIMATE
REGULATIONS AND MORE STATES
ACTUALLY LOOKING TO GET INTO.
THINGS LIKE PUTTING A PRICE ON
CARBON.
AYE I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO KEEP OUR MOMENTUM
GOING.
THANK YOU MISS SKINNER.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU BOTH FOR
THEIR PRESENTATION AND FOR TWO
CHEERS FOR.
HOLDING THE.
HEARING.
COUPLE COMMENTS COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
OF FOLLOWING UP ON SENATOR
STEARNS ISSUE OF.
THESE TYPES OF INCIDENTS THAT
CREATES THE UNANTICIPATED
EMISSIONS IN HERE OF COURSE
REFLECTING ON A LEASE OR CANYON
WE KNOW THERE'S ALSO.
.
WHICH WE CALL IT AND. JUST
ESCAPED.
WHETHER METHANE OR YES I FROM
OUR WHOLE SYSTEM OF OUR NATURAL
GAS SYSTEM. AND DE ESTIMATES ON
THAT VERY SO THAT'S ONE BUT THE
OTHER IS LIKE VW'S.
THEY'RE.
.
ALL COLLEGE KI?M HAD TO MOMENT.
INCREASE KNOCKS RIVER NOW I
DON'T KNOW I'D IF EFFECTED ALL
FUEL EFFICIENCY BUT KNOX'S A
GREENHOUSE GAS OR INDIRECT
GREENHOUSE GAS ANYWAY SO IT WAS.
WHAT LEVEL? OF.
.
OF INCREASED GHGS
THAT ACTION PUT NOW I RAISE
THESE ISSUES NOT THAT WE CAN SO
MUCH.
.
WE CAN'T PREDICT WHAT TYPE OF
UNANTICIPATED EMISSIONS BUT WE
CERTAINLY IT SEEMS TO ME.
THAT FOR OUR SCOPING PLAN.
WE SHOULD IN FUTURE.
YEAH I'D.
A COULD AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT THEN
AFFECT THE.
LIKE THE MARGIN BUT YEAH AFTER A
BLANK RIGHT FOR THE
UNANTICIPATED INSTEAD OF THE
ONLY.
SO WE HAVE THIS TARGET SO
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW AND BOOM
BOOM BOOM ONLY ON WHICH WE KNOW.
JUST A COMMENT QUICKLY ABOUT
pTHAT BEFORE I.
COHEN WELL.
YES IT YOU'RE MAKING A GOOD
POINT JUST ON THE ON THE
VOLKSWAGEN SITUATION WE WORKED
WITH THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN OUR ENFORCEMENT ACTION
AFTER WE UNCOVERED THE FRAUD.
WITH THE DEFEAT DEVICES THAT
THE COMPANY WAS USING THAT WE
NOT ONLY WERE WORKING TOWARDS
PENALTIES FOR WHICH WE SHOULD BE
NORMAL. BUT ALSO THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO ACQUIRE THE COMPANY TO
PUT MONEY INTO A SPECIAL FUND.
THAT WAS DESIGNED TO OB ALLOW
FOR AYE EVERY STATE THAT WAS
AFFECTED BY THIS WHICH WAS EVERY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY. AYE AND
AND TRIBES AS WELL ACTUALLY TO.
A RECEIVE FUNDS THAT COULD BE
USED TO CREATE NEW REDUCTIONS
AND KNOCKS.
THAT WOULD OFFSET LITERALLY
POUND FOR POUND THE ADDITIONAL
KNOCK STAFF COURSE THAT KNOCKS
THAT WAS RELEASED AS A RESULT OF
A VOLKSWAGEN DID IS ALREADY OUT
THERE THE ATMOSPHERE DOING ALL
THE HARM THAT IT COULD DO. BUT
GOING FORWARD WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INVEST IN PROGRAMS TO
HELP TURN OVER THE DIESEL FLEET
FOR EXAMPLE IN WAYS THAT WELL.
BILL THEN PERMANENT KNOCKS
REDUCTIONS WITH THE MONEY THAT
WILL BE GETTING OUT OF THAT FUND
SO I THINK ALL IN ALL THAT WAS
THAT. THAT WAS A TERRIFIC
SETTLEMENT UNFORTUNATELY AGAIN
I'M SORRY I JUST CAN'T RESIST
THIS BUT THE ARM WE'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
NOW DECIDED THEY DON'T WANT TO
DO THOSE KINDS OF SETTLEMENTS IN
THE FUTURE SO. WE HAVE ANOTHER
PENDING AYE CASE AGAINST ANOTHER
COMPANY THAT WAS DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BUT SOMEWHAT SIMILAR.
TO A VOLKSWAGEN DEAD AND.
WE WILL NOT BE GETTING THE SAME
AMOUNT OF HELP AND COLLABORATION
WITH THAT. AT WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE DID IN
THE PAST BOB BUT.
IN TERMS OF THE CERTAINTY THAT
WE HAVE OF ACHIEVING.
PRECISE LEVELS OF REDUCTION.
AS THE SCIENCE OF THIS IS SORT
OF IN ITS INFANCY I MEAN YOU CAN
MEASURE CO TWO DIRECTLY COMING
OUT OF THE STACK.
BUT TO MEASURE.
IN WITH GREAT PRECISION THE.
EMISSIONS OF.
METHANE THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
A PIPELINE OR UMPS AID MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT SOURCES.
WHO YOU WOULD HAVE TO AT
IMPLEMENTED A KIND OF MONITORING
SYSTEM THAT WE DON'T HALF NOW I
MEAN YOU CAN DO A PRETTY GOOD
JOB OF ESTIMATING BASED ON? THE
PRODUCT THAT'S PUT IN VERSUS THE
PRODUCT THAT YOU END UP WITH AT
THE OTHER END OF THE SYSTEM BUT.
IT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE PERFECT
AND OF COURSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA
KNOW. ON AN INDIVIDUAL BASIS
WHERE ALL THOSE EMISSIONS ARE
COMING FROM SO.
AND DO THAT.
I THINK A LOT OF THE CHANGES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ARE REALLY
CHANGES THAT TIGHTEN UP ON THE
WHOLE SYSTEMS OR THAT SUBSTITUTE
INHERENTLY LESS POLLUTING.
PRODUCTS AND TECHNOLOGIES
OVERALL SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
JUST KEEP PATCHING. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM BUT REALLY ARE LOOKING
FOR MORE TRANSFORMATIVE KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGIES.
SO WE. I THINK IT IS WORTH
CONSIDERING IN FUTURE UPDATES.
A.
.
THE PORTION OF THIS SCOPING PLAN
ON THE ON ANTICIPATED RUBEN.
SPEAKING TOWARDS THAT OF.
IT'S NOT A PERFECT SCIENCE
OR GO TO THE LA OR REPORT FOR
MINUTES SO.
YOU FOCUSED ON AND.
.
SHE BROWN YOU FOCUSED ON THE.
PORTION.
OF THAT IF THESE ALLOWANCES THAT
HAVE BEEN BANKED.
GET USED INSTEAD OF THE
REDUCTIONS THAT WE THAT THE CAP
AND TRADE SECTION AT LEAST WILL
NOT FULLY MEET THE TARGETS THAT
WE INTENT NOW. WHAT WHAT WASN'T
CLARIFIED WHICH I THINK IS
IMPORTANT CLARIFY IN THE
DISCUSSION IS THAT?
THE IN THE UPDATED SCOPING PLAN
AND AND MISS NICHOLS YOU CAN.
CLARIFY. DE THE AMOUNT OF SO WE
HAVE BEEN S. B. THIRTY TWO
GOALS.
YET DID SCOPING PLAN HAS
MEASURES IN VARIOUS THINGS AND
IT SHOWS WHAT PERCENT OF THAT
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAMS IS A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT.
WE EXPECT ABOUT THIRTY PERCENT
OF.
THE ACHIEVEMENT OF THE S. B.
THIRTY TWO GOAL IN THEIR CABIN
TREES ARE CORRECT.
YEAH I DON'T REMEMBER THE EXACT
NUMBER AND I THINK THE NEXT JOB
FORTY THIRD LITTLE DOES NOT
FORTY SNUFF FOR YOU CAN GET JUST
LIKE IT'S.
MAYBE THIRTY FIVE BUT IT'S
UNDER FORTY.
NOW EVEN IF
IT'S A. VERY WE HAVE THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO YOU DESCRIBED AS
FAR AS I CAN TELL YOU WOULD
STILL KNOCKER TOTAL TARGET OFF
BY LESS THAN TEN PERCENT.
GIVEN WHAT PERCENT IT IS OF OUR
OF WHAT WE INTENT.
SO NOW THAT'S NOT TO DIMINISH
THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT YOU
RAISED BUT I WONDER IF THE LA
ALWAYS PLANNING. IN A SIMILAR
SUSSMAN ON THE WHOLE SCOPING
PLAN.
AND THEY AN IVORY SICK BECAUSE.
WHILE THE CONTINUATION CAP AND
TRADE IS VERY IMPORTANT AND WAS
OBVIOUSLY VERY NON.
HE DID A.
IT DOMINATED MUCH OF OUR SESSION
LAST YEAR I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR. ALL OF US ON IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE STATE TO
REALIZE IT IS ONLY THIRTY
PERCENT OF OUR TOTAL GOAL.
AND SO IT AS WE FOCUS ON.
WHAT IT IS BEFORE US THAT WE
HAVE TO ACHIEVE
WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER THINGS WE
HAVE TO TO STAY FOCUSED ON?
AND SO WHAT.
ANYWAY COMMENT AND THEN ALL S.
DIVE TO OTHER QUESTIONS.
YEAH I'M GONNA.
.
I GUESS.
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR TO ME
KIND OF WHERE THE THE TEN
PERCENT SORT OF A LOOK ON ONLY
ON THIRTY PERCENT OF.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE S. B.
THIRTY TO CALL.
AND EVEN UNDER YOUR CHART.
IF ALL THE BANK EMISSIONS ARE
USED.
WHILE EMISSIONS WOULD BE HIGHER
THAN WHAT.
THE INTENT IS FOR CAPITATE
REDUCE THEY WILL NOT BE HIGHER
THAN THEY ARE TODAY.
SO WE WOULD STILL ACHIEVE
REDUCTION.
AND SO WHAT I'VE MY ESTIMATE TEN
PERCENT WAS A ROUGH BACK IN THE
ENVELOPE BUT THAT EVEN IF THE
WORST CASE SCENARIO OF BANKED
WE'D ONLY BE OFF BY THE OF THE
S. B. THIRTY TWO TARGET BY LESS
THAN TEN PERCENT OF TOTAL
EMISSIONS.
YEAH SO I THINK.
WHAT WE WHAT WE CANNOT WAIT OUT
IN THE CHART WAS THAT?
IT WOULDN'T BE THAT IT WOULD BE
THIRTY PERCENT LAST THING KIND
OF THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH CAP AND TRADE
THINK WHAT WE TRIED TO LAY OUT
AS THE SCENARIO WHERE. YOU EVEN
IF CAP AND TRADE AS THEIR
OVERALL EMISSIONS ARE EVEN
THIRTY PERCENT HIGHER THAN WHAT
THE ACTUAL TARGET IS SO IT'S
NOT.
SORT OF YOU KNOW THIRTY PERCENT
OF THE MISSION REDUCTIONS.
ANTICIPATED FROM CAP AND TRADE
THAT SORT OF A SCENARIO WHERE
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF THE
OTHER.
MEASURES THAT ARE IN PLACE AND
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS AND OTHER
THINGS AND EVEN PERHAPS SOME
INITIAL REDUCTIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH CAP AND TRADE. YOU COULD
STILL FIND YOURSELF IN A
SITUATION WHERE OVERALL
EMISSIONS.
FROM ALL SOURCES.
UNDER THE CAP UNDER THE CAP ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THIRTY
PERCENT HIGHER THAN WHAT THE
ACTUAL TARGET IS SO I THINK
MAYBE IT'S JUST.
AND BE HAPPY TO COME OUT.
CHAT ABOUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
SORT OF HOW IT RECONCILING THOSE
NUMBERS.
YOU'RE THE CHART ON THAT YOU
REFERENCE TO US ON PAGE EIGHT.
IS SOLELY AND ONLY.
EMISSIONS UNDER THE UNDER THE
CAP AND TRADE TARGET NOT THE
FULL AB THIRTY IT'S S. B. THIRTY
TWO PACKAGE THEY ARE THERE
EMISSIONS UNDER THE CAP FROM
CAPS SOURCES.
SO THAT INCLUDES KIND OF
TRANSPORTATION FUELS
ELECTRICITY.
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES.
THAT THE ONLY BANK ALLOWANCES
ARE ALLOWED UNDER CAP AND TRADE
NOT UNDER ANY OF THE OTHER.
RIGHT BUT THE THE OTHER.
AND MISSION REDUCTION POLICIES.
ESSENTIALLY ARE KIND OF
IMPLICITLY INCORPORATED IN THAT
RED LINE THAT YOU SEE THERE SO
THAT SORT OF STEADY DECLINE. IN
EMISSIONS RECKON ME DUE TO A
VARIETY OF FACTORS IN THIS
PARTICULAR EXAMPLE COULD BE JUST
OVERALL ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS. AS
WELL AS OR THE EFFECTS OF OTHER
CLIMB UP POLICIES THAT WE HAVE
THEIR AFFECTING THOSE OVERALL
EMISSIONS.
SO WE TRIED TO LAY OUT ISN'T
SCENARIO WHERE YEAH THERE THERE
THOSE POLICIES ARE HAVING SOME
EFFECT OF DRIVING DOWN.
EMISSIONS.
.
AND YET STILL WERE KIND OF WITH
THIS LARGE BANK OF ALLOWANCES
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM ISN'T
NECESSARILY NSURING THAT WERE
STILL MEETING OUR TWENTY THIRTY
GOAL.
.
OKAY I'VE. I THINK I HAVE TO.
READ YOUR REPORT CLOSER BECAUSE
YOUR CHART IT.
IT WOULD BE HARD TO INTERPRET
WHAT YOU JUST DESCRIBED FROM
LOOKING AT IT. THAT WAY.
AND.
.
DID.
THAT ON THE IF I MAY IT OF HOCUS
IS ALL THE ATTENTION ON THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM YEAH AND NOT
ENOUGH ON THE.
OPERATIONS OF THE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD LEAD
COMPANIES THAT ARE UNDER THIS
PROGRAM TO DECIDE WHETHER NOT
TO.
CLEAN UP VERSUS USE ALLOWANCES
HOLD ONTO ALLOWANCES AND THAT'S
PART OF WHAT MAKES THE WHOLE.
MARKET SYSTEM LESS THAN
PERFECTLY PREDICTABLE AS BECAUSE
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW AN
INDIVIDUAL%
EXECUTIVE OF A COMPANY IS GOING
TO LOOK AT. THE FUTURE YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW TECHNOLOGY PRICES ARE
GOING TO COME DOWN WHICH.
YOU KNOW SO FAR BASED ON
EXPERIENCE WE KEEP FINDING THAT
EVERYTHING WHETHER IT'S SOLAR
OR.
WHATEVER OUR GETS CHEAPER RATHER
THAN MORE EXPENSIVE AND SO
PEOPLE AND UP ACTUALLY DECIDING
TO CLEAN UP VERSUS.
BUYING ALLOWANCES AND THEREFORE
THE ALLOWANCES BECOME LESS
USEFUL AND LESS IMPORTANT EVEN
IF THEY'RE OUT THERE.
SO I PAID THEM WE DON'T I'M
ASSURE OTHER PEOPLE MAY ONE OF
FOLLOW THE BUT I DO WANNA GO
DEEPER IT NOW UNTIL I. READ THIS
HOLY SILICON ASK THE QUESTIONS
APPROPRIATELY BUT.
WAY IN MY LOOKING AT IT AND FROM
WHAT I HEARD YOU SAY. FIRE
HERDED AS THAT THIEF IF THE
COMPANIES USE THE FULL AMOUNT A
BANK ALLOWANCES.
THEY WOULD GO ABOVE WHAT THEY'RE
CAP IS UNDER CAP AND TRADE BUT
THAT THAT WOULD NECESSARILY
BRING US.
ABOVE.
OUR TOTAL S. B. THIRTY TWO
CHICHI REDUCTION GOAL NOW AGAIN
ALL LOOK AT IT MORE CAREFULLY
BUT THAT BRINGS ME. TO.
IF SINCE THE HEARINGS ON SCOPING
PLAN THAT AS MISS NICHOLS
POINTED OUT. OUR LARGEST SOURCE
OF EMISSIONS IS TRANSPORTATION.
AND TRANSPORTATION IS ONLY
MINIMALLY AFFECTED BY CAP AND
TRADE.
AND.
SO WE DO HAVE OBVIOUSLY OTHER
THINGS IN THE SCOPING PLAN
AROUND TRANSPORTATION.
BUT WHAT.
FOR ME. THAT THE.
OR CALL ABSENCE
OF CPAS
CIVIC.
GHG REDUCTION TARGETS IN VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE TRANSPORTATION.
SYRIA GIVEN HOW MUCH
OF OUR GIGI EMISSIONS IT IS.
I'M GIVES ME SOME CONCERN.
AND AND I AND I KNOW THAT WE ARE
HAVING GOOD SUCCESS FOR EXAMPLE
TO LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARDS I
KNOW THAT THERE'S WE'D YOU KNOW
WE'RE DOING LOTS OF WORK ON FOR
EXAMPLE ELECTRIFYING
TRANSPORTATION. BUT AGAIN I'M
THAT THAT ABSENCE OF.
MORE SOLID.
.
TARGETS RUN THE TRANSFERRED IN
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS GROWTH.
WELL I MEAN I THINK A SAID AN
AND INTERESTING AND USEFUL
COMMENT IT IS.
TRUE THAT THIS SCOPING PLAN
REALLY BUILDS ON PASSED SCOPING
PLANS AND PASS SCOPING PLANTS
HAVE BUILT ON THE EXISTING
REGULATORY PROGRAMS THAT WERE
ALREADY IN PLACE. AND IT COULD
BE THAT IF WE STEPPED BACK AND
SAID LET'S LOOK AT OUR ENTIRE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND FIGURE
OUT HOW YOU WOULD GET MORE.
REDUCTIONS OUT OF THAT.
YOU MIGHT COME UP WITH SOME
DIFFERENT IDEAS THAT.
IT'S A MY TWO LAST QUESTIONS ARE
ONE IS CARBON IN.
IN HOUSEHOLDS
SO WE'VE OBVIOUSLY HAVE ROBUST
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS WE'VE
GOT.
A FIFTY PERCENT.
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD NOW
BEFORE ASSIST POTENTIAL FOR A
HUNDRED PERCENT.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF CARBON
ESPECIALLY IN THE COASTAL
HOUSEHOLDS
WITHIN THEIR.
NATURAL GAS. THROUGH THEIR
WATER HEATING THEIR SPACE SEEING
THEIR.
.
OVENS IN SUCH DEMAND.
D. EFFICIENCY MEASURES.
ARE GOOD BUT THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY AIMED THEIR AIMED AT
DOING THAT MOST EFFICIENTLY BUT
NOT NECESSARILY DE CARBON ICING
THAT PORTION OF THE CARBON IN
OUR HOUSEHOLDS.
AND.
THE SCOPING PLAN DOESN'T REALLY
REFERENCE IT MUCH EITHER AND I
WONDERED IF CARP IS GIVEN MUCH
ATTENTION TO THAT.
WELL I THINK WHAT THE FOCUS OF A
THE FOCUS ON NATURAL GAS HAS
COME MORE THROUGH THAT SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
PROGRAM.
IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT.
WAYS YOU COULD.
MAKE A LARGER MORE DRAMATIC
REDUCTIONS IN EMISSIONS AND.
I KNOW THERE'S A.
A. SUGGESTION THAT IN THE FUTURE
WE SHOULD NOT. BE USED NATURAL
GAS AT ALL FOR SOME OF THE
PURPOSES THE AND WE WHERE YOU
COULD SUBSTITUTE ELECTRIFICATION
AND THE ELECTRICITY COULD COME
FROM RENEWABLE. RESOURCES
AND THE NATIONAL GAS INDUSTRY
HAS VERY.
AGGRESSIVELY REFUTED THAT IDEA
USING AS THE NOTION OF A SORT OF
A SYSTEM WHERE THEY COULD FIND
WAYS TO GET MORE GHG REDUCTIONS
OUT OF THEIR SYSTEM. THROUGH.
VARIOUS NEW TECHNOLOGY IS AS
YET NOT REALLY TESTED THAT BUT
OR BUT THAT THEY THEY COULD BE
TESTING THAT WOULD DEMONSTRATE
WAYS IN WHICH YOU COULD USE
NATURAL GAS TO ACTUALLY. REDUCE
A CO TWO EMISSIONS OVERALL FROM.
FROM MANY ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
DRIVING IF THEY USE SOME OF THAT
TO MAKE HYDROGEN IS MORE OF IT
TO MAKE HYDROGEN TO. OPERATE.
.
TO OPERATE JET FUEL CELLS SO AB
ED USE STORAGE AS A WAY THAT.
.
PUT TASK GAS
AB BACK INTO THE SYSTEM SO
ANYWAY I AM I THINK THESE.
KIND OF BIG POLICY ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE LIKE THAT BUT.
IN THE MEANTIME OUR FOCUS HAS
REALLY BEEN MORE ON WORKING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AND OTHER
AGENCIES THAT HAVE KIND OF
DIRECT RESPONSIBILITY OVER
BUILDING. AND EFFICIENCY OR
CITING OF FACILITIES AND SO
FORTH RATHER THAN KIND OF TRY TO
TAKE ON THAT THAT WHOLE ISSUE.
THEN LASTLY I WONDERED SORRY I
WONDERED IF CARD HAD LOOKED AT.
ANY DATA.
ON THE GHG REDUCTION DURING THE
PERIOD OF THE GOVERNOR'S WATER
USE REDUCTION ORDER.
.
I HAD SEEN SOME DATA.
THAT.
DUE TO THE WATER USE REDUCTION.
THAT ARE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THERE WAS WHATEVER LESS WATER
BEING PUMPED LESS WATER BEING
HEATED LESS WATER IT AND WE KNOW
THAT FOR EXAMPLE TWENTY PERCENT
OF ELECTRICITY IN THE STATE IS.
DO YOU JUST WATER PUMPING ALONE.
.
AND.
YOU KNOW AGAIN THE DATA I SAW.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER IT WAS.
.
BUT.
FROM A SMALL SOURCE OR WHETHER
IT WAS LARGER. BUT IT SEEMED
COMPELLING AND I WONDERED IF ANY
STATE AGENCIES WERE LOOKING AT
THAT.
THE WATER BOARD I BELIEVE HAS A
CONTRACT WITH.
THE CLIMATE.
REGISTRY TO DEVELOP A PROTOCOL
FOR LOOKING AT EXACTLY THAT.
ISSUE THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
MORE WATER USE EFFICIENCY AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS. BUT
TO MY KNOWLEDGE THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY BEEN COMPLETED.
THERE DEFINITELY IS CONTROVERSY
ABOUT THE QUESTION OF WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WATER IS CONSERVED
IS IT JUST SENT SOMEWHERE ELSE
AND IF SO HOW DOES THE ENERGY
ACTUALLY GET SAVED IN THE LONG
RUN. ME THIS NO QUESTION IF YOU
MAKE THE PUMPS MORE EFFICIENT
YOU'RE GOING TO SAVE.
EMISSIONS BECAUSE THERE'S
WHATEVER PUMPING IS DOWN WILL BE
USING CLASS AT WILL BE CREATING
FEWER EMISSIONS BUT IF YOU TALK
ABOUT WATER AS HOT AS A WHOLE AS
A SYSTEM. WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YOU REALLY HAVE TO
LOOK VERY CAREFULLY AT WHERE IT
GOES AND AND BUT GETS DONE OF
THAT CERTAINLY WOULDN'T BE
USEFUL GIVEN THAT WE HAD A
PERIOD OF TIME WAS THE
GOVERNOR'S REDUCTION ORDER IN
EFFECT ABOUT TWELVE MONTHS. AM.
SO THE MAN FEDERAL RATE OF TIME
RIGHT SO WE CAN PROBABLY GET THE
DATA I'M FROM ME AGAIN I'M NOT
GOING TO TRY TO SPECULATE WOULD
BE THE BEST SOURCES BUT WE COULD
BE SINCE WE KNOW THE WINDOW. IF
PERIOD AND WE KNOW WHAT WATER
USE REDUCTION WAS ACHIEVED
COULDN'T WE GET USING THAT. TIME
PERIOD DATA FROM THE THE
APPROPRIATE ENTITIES TO LOOK AT
WHETHER THERE WAS A ASSOCIATED.
REDUCTION IN.
ELECTRICITY YOU'RE NOW TO THE
OTHER USE. WHICH WOULD THEN GIVE
US SOME INSIGHT RATHER THAN.
BECAUSE AGREED WE WE DON'T KNOW
BROADLEAF WHETHER THE SAVING OF
WATER IN FACT
IT'S JUST SAVING IT HERE AND
ISN'T NECESSARILY GET USED
ELSEWHERE BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE
THIS SNAPSHOT WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO GET SOME REAL DATA.
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD JOB FOR THE
ALEJO.
YEAH.
THANK YOU CHARLIE.
THAT WAS IT.
DID YOU MIND IF I. JUST ADD ONE
THING ON THAT POINT.
THAT I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
RECENTLY RELEASED STUDY OR AT
LEAST A WORKING PAPER. WHICH I
BELIEVE WAS LOOKING AT WATER
CONSERVATION EFFORTS AND
CALIFORNIA AND EFFORTS TO
PROMOTE WATER CONSERVATION AND
HOUSEHOLDS ONE OF THE FINDINGS
SEEM TO BE. ADJUSTED WHO NOT
ONLY TO THOSE EFFORTS SHORT OF.
AFFECT WATER CONSERVATION
PROMOTE CONSERVATION WATER AND
ENERGY ASSOCIATED WITH LEADING
ARE MOVING THAT WATER. BUT ALSO
IT HAD TREATING IT LATER RIGHT
BUT IT ALSO HAD THE.
AFFECT OF AFFECTING PEOPLE'S
BEHAVIOR JUST ON THEIR SHARE
ELECTRICITY USE.
AND SO THERE WAS KIND OF AN
INTERESTING AND I THINK
HYPOTHESIS THAT MAYBE JUST OR
GREATER ATTENTION TO THINGS LIKE
WATER CONSERVATION COULD ALSO
HAVE SOME POTENTIAL SPILLOVER
EFFECTS ON. OTHER TYPES OF
ENERGY USE ON HAPPY TO. TRY AND
FIND THAT I THINK WORKING PAPER
IN AND SEND IT TO YOU.
CASE YOU'RE INTERESTED.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER WHO TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MISTER
CHAIR FOR.
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER THIS IS
ONE OF THE.
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE TO MEET.
.
CHAIRPERSON HIGH NICHOLS AND.
AND ANSWER SOME REALLY POINTED
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
THE SCOPING PLAN. OF ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW IT IT.
TOOK TWO YEARS FOUR MONTHS AND
SIX DAYS TO GET SB ONE APPROVED.
THAT'S THE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING BILL.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE IT WAS
LIKE HERDING CATS TRYING TO GET
THIS COMPREHENSIVE.
FIX TO TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF. DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ON THE HIGHWAYS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SCOPING
PLAN IS COMING TO ME IT'S
COUNTERINTUITIVE WHEN WE START
TAKING AND REDUCING VEHICLE
TRAVELED MILES.
WITH CARS WHICH THEN NOW IF WE
REDUCING THAT WE'RE REDUCING THE
INPUT OF MONEY INTO THE MAIN
THIS OF HIGHWAYS. AND PUTTING
MORE RESERVES WHICH IS A
LAUDABLE GOAL. BUT WE ACTUALLY.
HAD SUCH A HARD TIME TRYING TO
EVEN GET A FIGURE IMPLEMENTED.
FOR DESERVES TO BE PART OF THE
REGISTRATION.
TO PAY THEIR SHARE SOMEWHAT OF A
SHARE. OF THEIR IMPACT ON THE
ROADS.
SO.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THE VEHICLE
MILES OR THE ROAD USER CHARGE WE
EVER IN THE NEAR FUTURE BE.
ADOPTED BECAUSE OF PUBLIC.
ANGST WITH HOW.
IT'S PERCEIVED AS BIG BROTHER.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT WE WORK SO
HARD TO GET.
AND TRYING TO MAINTAIN THE ROADS
FOR THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA
WITH THE FREIGHT DYNAMIC AND AND
WHAT OT AND THE AND SAFETY AND
AND ALL THE THINGS IMPACTED BUT
HERE. THIS SCOPING PLAN TAKES
AWAY FROM IT.
HOW DO WE ADDRESS THAT GOING
FORWARD NUMBER ONE?
AND THEN.
WE'RE LOOKING AT.
.
YOU KNOW SOLUTIONS HOW DO WE GET
TO YES RIGHT.
WE WANT TO BE.
.
CONSCIOUS OFATTAINMENT OF OF OF
THE AGENCY'S GOALS.
BUT.
THEN AGAIN WE HAVE A PROGRAM
THAT ACTUALLY DIMINISHES ANOTHER
AGENCIES GOALS.
AND SO.
THAT BEING SAID.
YOU KNOW.
.
I WOULD HOPE THAT THAT THERE CAN
BE SOME KIND OF DISCUSSION.
ON AND AND I KNEW I HAD A REALLY
GOOD AUTHORISATION WITH RICHARD
YOU'RE YOU'RE NEAR EXACT
DIRECTOR. ABOUT PARTNERING.
WITH.
CALTRANS IN THE PORTS ABOUT
MINIMIZING CONGESTION OUT OF THE
PORTS BASED ON.
.
IMPACTS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LIKE WE WE WE
REGULATE THE PORT TO THE GATE.
AND THEN FROM THAT POINT
FORWARD.
WE DON'T CARE.
AND SO.
BUT THE LARGEST IMPACT ON THE
COMMUNITIES IS PASS I GAVE.
AND SO I WAS HOPING THAT IN THE
SCOPING FAMILY WE WOULD ADDRESS
THAT IN ITS THEN IT COULD BE TO
THE STRATEGIC FREE PLAN ALSO.
THAT THAT THERE'S A PARTNERSHIP
WITH STATE AGENCIES THAT
ACTUALLY IF WE REDUCE
CONGESTION.
THERE ARE SO MANY BY PRODUCTS OF
VALUE THAT CAN BE HAD.
WERE WE GET MORE THROUGHPUT
MOBILITY FOR THE ECONOMY.
WE AT REDUCE THE IMPACT ON THE
LOCAL NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WE ACTUALLY THEN ARE MORE OF
VIABLE TWO OTHER SOURCES OF
SHIPPERS WHO WANT TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
DOING FORTY PERCENT AND.
HE'LL THE STIGMA IS THAT WERE SO
OVER REGULATED NOW THAT A LOT OF
SHIPPERS ARE CONSIDERING BECAUSE
THEY CAN.
BECAUSE OF THE PANAMA CANAL
EXPANSION GO ELSEWHERE.
AND DID BEING THAT'S A THIRD OF
OUR ECONOMY ONE OF OUR LARGEST
WORKFORCE IS WHAT I'M HOPING
THAT WE.
AS A AS A WHOLE CAN IDENTIFY
REAL GOOD WORK AND THOSE REPORTS
HAVE BEEN FANTASTIC ABOUT
PARTNERING.
BUT IN THE SCOPING PLAN I DON'T
SEE ANY MENTION. OF.
THAT.
VIABILITY OF OF TAKING.
A LEAD ROLE WITH WITH NOW THAT
WE'VE DONE THIS WITH SP ONE.
THERE'S MONEY.
AND AND AND INCENTIVIZING THAT
PROCESS WE LOOK AT ANOTHER VENUE
SO HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT WELL
AND. I THINK. ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU'RE POINTING OUT IS THAT NO
ONE AGENCY SHOULD OR COULD BE IN
CONTROL OF ALL OF THE GOOD
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH AT THE SAME TIME. AND
THAT YOU NEED AT A GOVERNOR AND
AGENCIES THAT ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO COORDINATE THOSE
DIFFERENT CALLS AND I SIT AS A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE SUSTAINABLE
FREIGHT. WORKING GROUP I'M I'M
JUST ONE MEMBER BUT WE HAVE A
LOT OF INTERACTION WITH OF STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY AND
CALTRANS AND THE PORTS AROUND
THAT EXACT ISSUE.
AND TO RIGHT BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS I MET WITH THE.
SHIPPERS TO TALK ABOUT.
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION GOING FORWARD. UP
PARTICULARLY AROUND HOW THEY CAN
GET TO THE KINDS OF INCREASES IN
EFFICIENCY AND SPEED OF
THROUGHPUT THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR WITHOUT JUST BEING.
SADDLED WITH MORE REGULATORY
BURDENS SO IT'S EXACTLY THE
ISSUE THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND WE ARE VERY ARAB COMMITTED
TO THAT GOAL OF. MAINTAINING AND
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL.
ROLE HAS SAID LOGISTICS AT THE
STATE AND SO. WE TRY TO WORK
WITH OUR SISTER AGENCIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER REGULATIONS
WERE CONSIDERING OUR PROGRAMS
ARE CONSIDERING. ARE ALSO A
CONGRUENT WITH WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING AND.
AYE WE FOUND CONVERSELY THAT
YOU KNOW OUR SISTER AGENCIES
WHILE CLIMATE CHANGE MAY NOT BE
THEIR BIGGEST AT THEIR THEIR
NUMBER ROAD.
I OPERATIONS SO I FEEL LIKE HOME
AS WE ALL A IS SORT OF LIKE
SAYING YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THE IMPACTS OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING ON EVERYBODY ELSE
BEFORE YOU. TAKE ACTION BUT IT
IS TRUE THAT THE SCOPING PLAN IN
AND OF ITSELF DOES NOT REFERENCE
ALL THE OTHER. PLANS THAT IT IT
PASSED TO BE COORDINATED WITH
AND MAYBE THERE'S A BETTER WAY
FOR THE STATE TO SORT OF.
HIGHLIGHTED THE FACT THAT WE HAD
THESE DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES THAT
WE'RE ALL WORKING ON.
AND IT JUST IF YOU COULD TOUCH
ON THE OF REDUCTION OF OF.
I WOULD SAY FUNDING FOR THE
TRICKS OF THE ROAD. MAIN IS FUN
WHICH WITH THROUGH THIS.
THESE GOALS RIVER COULD YOU
ADDRESS OUT OF HOW HOW HOW THAT
YOUR YOUR QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
ELECTRIFICATION OF VEHICLES IS
AUTOMATICALLY R. OR WILL LEAD TO
REDUCTION IN.
.
REVENUE YOU FOR FURTHER OUR
ROADS IS THAT AS A.
A GOOD QUESTION BUT. AT THIS
POINT WE'RE SO FAR FROM HAVING
THE KIND OF NUMBERS THAT WOULD
REALLY HAVE THAT IMPACT THAT
IT'S HARD TO SAY. IT IS TRUE
THAT OVER TIME.
IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL.
PETROLEUM IS USE IS GONNA GO
DOWN AND THAT WILL MEAN THAT
OTHER WAYS TO ACHIEVE REVENUE
SERVE AGAIN IN BE NEEDED BUT.
WE HAVEN'T LOOKED THAT FAR INTO
THE FUTURE BECAUSE IT'S AS MUCH
AS WE CAN DO RIGHT NOW TO PLAN
FOR. YOU KNOW TWENTY THIRTY AND
THINK ABOUT HEADING TOWARDS
TWENTY FIFTY AND WE AB BASED ON
ALL THE NUMBERS THAT I'VE SEEN.
IT EVEN IN TWENTY FIFTY THERE'S
GOING TO BE VERY LARGE NUMBERS
OF PETROLEUM CARS. ON THE ROADS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE.
MOON UNIT TOOK TWENTY THREE
YEARS TO GET AN ADJUSTMENT IN
ANY KIND OF FIX.
AND SO IF WE LOOK ABOUT TO DO
DIMINISHING RETURNS THAT WE WORK
TOWARDS A DIMINISHING RETURN OF
FUNDING WHERE RD SEVENTY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE HOLE.
WERE ONLY GETTING FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND NOT
ALL THAT'S GOING TO ROSE WHOSE
OTHER PROGRAMS. AND SO I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE LOOK AT THAT IN
SAYING THAT YOU KNOW.
EVEN IF WE HAVE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THEY NEED TO HAVE
HIGHWAYS ARE THERE EFFECTIVE IN
AND SAFE.
YOU KNOW AND THEN AGAIN IT'S A
VERY LAUDABLE GOAL HAVE ELECTRIC
TRUCKS.
BUT IF THEY'RE JUST SITTING IN
CONGESTION NOT MOVING.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE A LOT MORE
MONEY AND. WHY WOULD SO MANY BY
IT IF THEY'RE JUST SITTING
OUTSIDE OF THAT COURT?
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
AND I'D LIKE TO ADDRESSING AND
CONTINUE. THROUGH THIS PROCESS
BECAUSE OUR AND AGAIN WHAT LOVE
ABSOLUTE WHAT YOU'VE
ACCOMPLISHED AND I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING. BUT I THINK THERE'S
ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE THAT HAS TO
BE CLEAN AND AND TAKEN IN
CONSIDERATION.
GOINGFORWARD AND.
YOU KNOW I KEEP HARPING ON THAT
BECAUSE I I SEE. THAT WE GETS IN
SILOS AND WE AND WE LOOK CERTAIN
ASPECTS.
BUT NOT IN ANY GIVEN I I
APPRECIATE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE A COMPONENT OF
THIS I DON'T SEE.
A BUSINESS DYNAMIC IN THIS OTHER
THAN THE MARKET ANALYSIS
COMPONENT.
A I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A FAIR AND
BALANCED.
IN.
IN THE SCOPING PLANS IN AND AND
AND IMPLEMENTATION.
OF GOING FORWARD YOU KNOW I MEAN
I HAVE THREE DELTA.
COMMISSIONS ADULTS ARE SEWER
SHIP COULD COUNSEL THOUGH
BECAUSE I DON'T CONSERVANCY IN
THE DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION.
HANDS ALL BASED AROUND THIS
TWIN TOTAL ASPECT RIGHT.
BUT WE ONLY HAVE ONE LITTLE
COMPONENT.
WHEN WE HAVE THIS HUGE DYNAMIC
OF MORE THE SIXTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
AND SO I THINK THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY HAS TO BE EMBRACED AT
SOME POINT. NOT AT SOME POINT
NOW.
UGH THAT IT IS IS A KEY DYNAMIC
FIGURE AND. EMPLOYED FOR THE
SCOPING PLANS AND IT IS IN NOT
SO I JUST RECEIVED A ONE YEAR
AND OUT THE OTHER. THAT ACTUALLY
INCLUDE IS IS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE EXPERTS
OKAY.
AND I'M NOT SAYING YOU GUYS ARE.
THEY DO IT DAY IN AND DAY OUT IN
A I WOULD HOPE THAT WE WOULD.
RECEIVE THIS EXPORTED ADVICE AND
INPUT.
TO BE ABLE TO COUNTER BALANCE
AND AGAIN WE'VE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION WHERE.
ROME WASN'T BUILT IN A DAY WE
CAN GET HERE OVERNIGHT.
A GLIDE PATH BACK TO SUCCESS.
IN MY MY WORLD.
WHEN IT DOESN'T DAMAGE THE
ECONOMY OR AND AND AND THE
CONSUMER'S WALLET. IS IS A GREAT
WAY TO GO AFTER THOSE YOU KNOW
AND SO I HAVE JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION.
.
IT REALLY HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED
IN MISTER STEARNS QUESTION ABOUT
THE WILDFIRES.
REALLY IF YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE
GOOD WORK THAT YOU DO DURING THE
YEAR WITH EURASIA SANTA AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THEN WE HAVE
THESE DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
THAT CAN ZERO ZERO OUT. WHAT
YOU'VE DONE ANY YEAR?
IZZARD ABILITY FOR.
YOUR AGENCY AND COLLABORATION OR
CAL FIRE AND OTHER AGENCIES.
TO MITIGATE.
.
LOOK AT.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
PRACTICES.
YOU KNOW WE USED TO HAVE
GRAZING ON STATE LANDS.
WE DON'T ANYMORE AND I'M WHAT
I'M HEARING FROM IS THE FUELS
ARE GETTING LARGER AND GETTING
UP INTO THE CANOPY IS BECAUSE OF
THIS.
AND ANY LOOK AT MAYBE. FASTER
RESPONSES OR WHATEVER IT WATER
THAT IS.
BUT.
FOR EVERY STEP WE TAKE FOR WE
TAKE TWO STEPS BACK IF THERE'S A
NATIONAL DISASTER LIKE THIS.
AND SO WHAT WE GAINED IF WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND I'M
HOPING THAT YOU GUYS CAN
ADDRESS.
THAT COUPLE AND AGAIN ACT OF GOD
WHATEVER IT IS I UNDERSTAND. BUT
CAN WE BE A PART OF THAT.
EQUATION.
SO THAT WE ACTUALLY DO.
INCREASE IN VALUE.
THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS DO.
I THINK YOU'RE ON THE OUTSIDE
I'VE I I INDICATED WE ARE.
WORKING WITH THE RESOURCES
AGENCY NATURISTS US AGENCY AND
OUT CALLIE PA AND THE
CONSTITUENT DEPARTMENTS SAT OVER
RESOURCES.
ON THIS ARE APPROACH TO MANAGING
OUR FORESTS FOR HEALTH AT WHICH
INCLUDES BEING ABLE TO STORE
CARBON. OTHER NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS ARE ALSO IMPORTANT
RANGELANDS.
WETLANDS AT RIGHT PARIAN AREAS
AND WE'VE GOT.
EVEN OUR STATE PARKS.
HAVE IN SOME INSTANCES GOT
DEGRADED.
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY REALLY
AREN'T ABLE TO STORE IS MUCH
CARBON AS THEY.
AS THEY SHOULD AND SO.
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THESE
THINGS IN THE CONTEXT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT'S ALREADY ONGOING
AND THE STRESSES THAT THESE
PLACES ALREADY ARE ACHIEVING. TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN DO
NOW.
TO HELP MAKE THEM HEALTHIER
THAN THEY ARE AND OBVIOUSLY A RB
DOES NOT HAVE THAT.
THE WISDOM TO KNOW ALL OF IT
ALL THAT WE HAVE AT LEAST AT. IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS AND INVESTED
IN TERMS OF BRINGING OUT SOME
STAFF THAT HAVE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
AGRICULTURE AND AND.
LANDSCAPE ISSUES BUT.
THAT WE DEFINITELY NEED TO BE
PARTNERING WITH THESE WITH THESE
OTHER AGENCIES APPRECIATE
MAKING.
THINKING IS A FACIAL.
MISLIM ON.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR STERN AND ALSO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER COMMENTS
BECAUSE I WANTED TO INQUIRE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
.
IN IN TERMS OF I KNOW THAT UNDER
KIND OF SHORT LIVED CLIENTS WE
TALK ABOUT THE BLACK CARBON AND
AND.
REPRESENTING A DISTRICT THAT HAS
JUST HAD THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY. AND WHO
SPENT A MONTH OF WEARING MASKS
AND KNOWING THAT IN PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT. THE AIR QUALITY GOT TO
HAZARDOUS NOXIOUS BAD THAT
HAZARDOUS.
AND HOW YOU KNOW ON DECEMBER
NINTH OUR GOVERNOR SAID. THIS
IS.
NOW THE NORM.
CALIFORNIA'S TALKING ABOUT.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY CAN NO
LONGER STAFF ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS AND WILL HAVE TO STAFF ON
A TWELVE MONTH BASIS.
SO KNOWING ALL OF THIS.
IS THERE ARE ABILITY TO RETHINK.
ALL TOGETHER THE MEASUREMENT
ASPECT NOT JUST WHAT WE DO TO
CAPTURE CARBON RIGHT BUT ALSO
THE HOW WE MEASURE.
BECAUSE I IT'S A NEW REALITY FOR
S. I WISH IT WASN'T SO. I WISH
WE DIDN'T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT
BUT IF WE'RE NO LONGER TALKING
ABOUT SHORT LIVED WHAT KIND OF.
EVIDENCE DO WE NEED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THE
MEASUREMENT ASPECT
DEBATE.
MANY THINK IT YOU KNOW AGAIN
THIS IS
IT VERY NEAR IN DEEP THE FIRE
STILL BURNING IN MY DISTRICT.
IT'S NOT OUT YET.
BUT.
.
YOU KNOW HOW DOES THE PUBLIC
THINK ABOUT THIS.
WELL I THINK YOU ALREADY GIVEN A
LOT OF THOUGHT TO THE ISSUE I'M
NOT SURE EIGHT. HOW DO I RESPOND
EXCEPT TO SAY FIRST OF ALL WITH
RESPECT TO THE EXPOSURES THAT
PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING? ARM
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF PROGRESS
IN RECENT YEARS. IN MEASURING
EXPOSURE AS OPPOSED TO JUST
STICKING A MONITOR OUT SOMEWHERE
AND LOOKING AT WHAT THAT HAPPENS
TO CAPTURE. SO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO AND.
TO DEPLOY.
BACKPACK SIZE MONITORS THAT YOU
COULD.
UTILIZED TO GET A BETTER SENSE
OF THE LONGER TERM HEALTH
EFFECTS AND THE SHORT TERM
AFFECTS OF.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE'S A
FIRE THAT THAT NOT THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T PEOPLE OBVIOUSLY FIRST
OF ALL NEED TO GET AWAY FROM THE
DANGER BUT THEN WHEN THEY COME
BACK AGAIN INTO COMMUNITIES
WHERE THE FIRES ARE? YOU KNOW
NOT RIGHT NEXT TO THEM THE AIR
QUALITY CAN STILL BE VERY BAD.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE
LOOKING AT NOT ONLY MEASURING
WHAT PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING BUT
ALSO LOOKING AT WAYS TO. PROTECT
THEM BETTER IN THOSE SITUATIONS
FROM THE IMPACTS OF OF WHAT
THEIR BREATHING AND WE'RE NOT
REALLY AT AT THIS POINT. THING
GEARED UP TO DO THAT VERY
EFFECTIVELY I THINK WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE LOCAL DISTRICTS TO. GET
TIMELY INFORMATION OUT TO PEOPLE
ABOUT WHAT THE AIR QUALITY IN
THEIR AREA IS LIKE AND TO MAKE
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO.
AVOID. BREATHING TOO MUCH OF IT
BUT IT OUT IT'S STILL IS NOT A.
IT'S NOT A SITUATION THAT I
THINK IS IDEAL THE.
THE MESSAGE AND I KNOW THAT.
PEOPLE AND THEIR.
NATURAL RESOURCES FIELD AND IT.
CAL FIRE FOR YEARS HAVE TRIED
TO WORK WITH LOCAL LAND USE
AGENCIES TO.
AT.
TRY TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT ADD
TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL ABOUT
BUILDING ON THE EDGE OF THE
FOREST AND THE NEED TO HAVE
CLEARED AREAS AROUND WHERE
PEOPLE ARE LIVING AND NOT. TO
CONTINUE TO.
JUST YOU KNOW. HAVE.
DEVELOPMENT KIND OF IN THE
MIDST OF A FORESTED AREAS WHERE
IT ISN'T REALLY EFFECTIVE IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIGHT FIRES ONCE
THEY START. AND I THINK THAT'S
GONNA BE AN AREA THAT THEY WOULD
NEEDS TO BE MORE ATTENTION PAID
I KNOW.
LOOKING AT.
GUIDELINES FOR THAT TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITHIN.
PROBABLY THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL AND ELSEWHERE ITEM AT I
MEAN I THINK WE JUST ALL AS A
STATE ARE GONNA HAVE TO BE MUCH
MORE CONSCIOUS OF THE RISK.
THEN WE HAVE BEEN A FAR.
THIS BURKE.
I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION.
A WAS BACK TO US CENTER
SKINNER'S QUESTION WHICH
SO TRIED AND IT'S BACK TO BEING
THE BANKING.
SO TRADITIONALLY WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN EARLY TO MEET OUR GOALS BUT
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WITH
THIRTY PERCENT AND PERCENT RANGE
OF OF ARTICLES BEING MET BY CAP
AND TRADE.
AND.
I AM TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH OF BANKING OF THE BANKING
OF OF CREDITS IS REALLY GOING
TO.
.
BE IN ISSUE AND HOW FAR IN
ADVANCE WE WOULD HAVE TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE LEGISLATIVELY BECAUSE
YOU SAID IT'S A POLICY ISSUE.
I'M WONDERING HOW FAR IN ADVANCE
FROM TWENTY THIRTY WE WOULD HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION OR ENOUGH
DATA. TO KNOW WHEN WE WOULD HAVE
TO AFFECT THAT POLICY.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION I I DON'T
HAVE A CLEAR ANSWER FOR YOU I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE. LOOKING AT
THE ALBUM DESIGN OF THE PROGRAM
GOING FORWARD. MIA AS WE MOVE IT
TO TWENTY TWENTY AND BEYOND TO
HAVE SOME MEASURES OF FOR.
TAKING STOCK OF WHERE THAT
ALLOWANCES ARE AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THEM. TO HAVE A
BETTER PICTURE OF IT. BUT I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE TRY
TO KEEP REMINDING OURSELVES THAT
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM IS IT
IS SORT OF LIKE.
TRADING IN DERIVATIVES IT'S
TRADING ENOUGH AN INSTRUMENT IF
NOT TRADING IN A REAL PHAGOCYTE
IT OUT IT AT ALL VIOLENCE
REPRESENTS AN ABILITY TO IN THAT
IT DOESN'T REPRESENT THE ACTUAL
EMISSION. AND SO IF YOU'RE
TRACKING WHERE THE EMISSIONS ARE
COMING FROM WHICH WE CAN DO
WITHOUT THE REPORTED DATA.
THEN YOU CAN SEE IF THERE'S
SOME TYPE OF SOURCE WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING INCREASES IN ACTUAL
EMISSIONS AND PEOPLE USING
ALLOWANCES TO COMPLY. AND THEN
YOU WOULD HAVE A MUCH BETTER
SENSE OF WHERE YOU NEEDED TO GO
WITH A MORE TARGETED. APPROACH
AND I THINK WITH THE ANNUAL.
REPORTING AND.
REVEALING THAT WE'RE DOING THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE THOSE
KINDS OF TRENDS HAPPENING OBEY
SO FAR THE GOOD NEWS IS SPEND
THAT ON THAT. EITHER ELECTRICITY
SIDE WE'VE SEEN OUR REDUCTIONS
HAPPENING FASTER THAN WE THOUGHT
THEY WERE GONNA HAPPEN THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO SEE RIGHT IS YOU
KNOW THE CULMINATION OF PRICING
ON THE REGULATIONS.
MOVING PEOPLE IN THE DIRECTION
THAT THAT WE ALL WANTED TO GO
BUT DOING IT EVEN FASTER BECAUSE
THE PRICES START TO COME DOWN
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY.
THAT OBVIOUSLY HAS NOT HAPPENED
DID AND UP IN THE PLAY.
AND THE PROCESS THAT WE CAN
UNDERTAKE MOVING FORWARD. AS A
RACE TO ADDITIONAL DIRECT
MEASURE. REDUCTIONS.
THAT COULD BE ADOPTED AND I ASK
THOSE TWO QUESTIONS IN THE
CONTEXT OF. THE DEFINING OF THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
AS A DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTION
MEASURE.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE STILL
LOVE QUESTIONS AND.
.
PEOPLE LOOKING FOR SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THAT. AS IT
RELATES TO THE CONFLICT THAT IT.
SEEMS TO BE ARE PRESENTING OR
HOW IT'S BEING INTERPRETED
RELATED TO AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
IT'S DIRECTED MISSION REDUCTION
MEASURES. IN PLACE.
THIS IS A I KNOW A DEFINITIONAL
PROBLEM AND AYE I AM DON'T WANNA
BE AND.
NO ONE IS I DON'T TRY TO BRUSH
IT OVER AT THE SAME TIME I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE.
POINT OUT THE FACT THAT THE.
.
DIRECT EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS.
OCCUR FOR VARIOUS REASONS FOR
EXAMPLE A PROGRAM THAT PAYS
PEOPLE TO TURN IN AN OLD CAR AND
GIVES THE MONEY TO BUY A NEW
CAR.
IS STILL A DIRECT EMISSION THE
REDUCTION IN THE SENSE THAT AN
OLD CAR IS BEING SCRAPPED AND A
NEW CAR IS GOING ON TO THE ROAD
SO. REAL EMISSIONS ARE ARE BEING
REDUCED.
SOME OF OUR MARKET BASED
MEASURES GET DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS OUR EVEN THOUGH THEY
UTILIZE A DIFFERENT WAY OF.
GETTING THERE AND I THINK THAT'S
MAYBE BEEN A PROBLEM OF
TERMINOLOGY AS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN.
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
THE DESIRE OF THAT I NO I.
PEOPLE HAVE FELT
TO HAVE MORE MEASURES THAT
TARGETED AN INDIVIDUAL SOURCE
SOURCE BY SOURCE AND SAID THOU
SHALT NOT EMIT MORE THAN EXT
AMOUNT AND IF YOU DO. IT OUT BAD
THINGS WILL HAPPEN TO YOU.
.
OUR ANALYSIS IN THE SCOPING PLAY
AND WHERE WE LOOKED AT BOTH
CERTAINTY OF ACHIEVING THE
OVERALL GOALS AND THE COST OF
ACHIEVING THE OVERALL GOALS. WAS
THAT YOU REALLY NEEDED A MIX OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MEASURES.
ALL OF WHICH WERE FOCUSED ON
GETTING YOU.
.
REDUCTIONS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
TRYING TO FIND THE ONES WHERE
THE STATE WILL HAVE TO PAY LAST.
OUT OF PUBLIC FUNDS AND WHERE.
YOU COULD MAKE SURE THAT THE
REDUCTIONS WERE ACTUALLY
HAPPENING SO. AND WE HAVE
HAD A VERY. STRONG CONFIDENCE
LEVEL THAT WE CAN MONITOR HOW
MANY ALLOWANCES ARE OUT THERE WE
KNOW WHO HAS THEM WE KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH THEM AND OUT
WE KNOW WHAT THEY'RE FOR. AND WE
KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL EMISSIONS
OF THE FACILITIES ARE AND SO WE
CAN USE THOSE TO DRIVE DOWN. THE
EMISSIONS FROM THOSE INDIVIDUAL
SOURCES FACILITIES THAT ARE
UNDER UNDER THE PROGRAM.
BUT WE'VE TRIED TO COMPARE.
PROGRAM BY PROGRAM OR STRATEGY
BY STRATEGY.
ACROSS THE WHOLE FIELD OF
OPPORTUNITIES AND TO I'M
EVALUATE THEM THAT WAY IN
COMPARISON.
IN COMPARISON WITH EACH OTHER.
SO I TRY RAISE THE QUESTION
BREAK BECAUSE ENDED DEBATE AND
DELIBERATION OF A AB ONE NINETY
SEVEN THERE WAS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ASKED IN TERMS OF WHAT
IMPACT AND THAT IT HAD ON THE
CAP AND TRADE.
PROGRAM WAY IN THERE WAS A
CONSENSUS THAT THAT WOULD WOULD
NOT.
BE THE FINDER CONSIDERED A AT
LEAST A CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AS
A DIRECT MISSION.
THAT REDUCTION THE TOOLOR FOR
MY THREE MINUTE RATE THEMSELVES
UP I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE STILL LACK OF OF. CAMP
CONSENSUS AROUND THAT
CONVERSATION I WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO KIND OF.
HIGHLIGHT.
THOSE DISCREPANCIES EXIST HiA
WITHIN THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY.
AROUND THIS ISSUE OF BUT.
A DIRECT COMMISSION MEASURE I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
.
CERTAINLY I GROUPS AND
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
WHO REMAIN UNCOMFORTABLE LESS.
THAT JUST DON'T THINK IT'S A
GOOD WAY TO GO. AND.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT I
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO CONVINCE THEM
JUST LIKE THEY MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO CONVINCE ME. BUT HAVING SAID
THAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTE AND
WE'RE VERY.
CONFIDENT THAT WE ARE COMPLYING
WITH THE. LETTER AND THE SPIRIT
OF ONE NINETY SEVEN I THINK IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO STILL FEEL
THAT THEY WANTED SOMETHING
DIFFERENT OR SHOULD OF GOTTEN
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
FROM ONE NINETY SEVEN.
I I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT I HAD BUT
I DON'T FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN ANY
DANGER IN TERMS OF OUR.
LEGAL SITUATION.
WHAT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE HANDFUL
OF THE AUTHORS OF THE BILL RIGHT
THAT WE KNOW WHAT OUR INTENTIONS
WARY WAS CERTAINLY TIPPED UP
BRING FORWARD SOME SOME? FORM OF
RELIEF ON THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND NOT REALLY.
BANK ON THAT AS THE TOOL AND DIE
SO THE DIRECT ADMISSION
COMPONENT EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BUT IT'S A CONVERSATION I THINK
THEY OUGHT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
AN IS CERTAINLY.
NOT ONE WHERE YOU KNOW WE'LL GO
BACK AND FORTH TRYING TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE BUT CERTAINLY
FOCUSED ON WHAT'S.
YOU KNOW ON IN WRITING IN STATUE
IN AND I TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WELL AND AGAIN I I KNOW I TALKED
A LOT ABOUT SIX SEVENTEEN IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS HEARING TODAY.
BUT THERE WAS A REASON FOR THAT
HOME WHICH HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT I BELIEVE THAT THE.
PRINCIPAL CONCERN OF PEOPLE
ABOUT THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
IS NOT ABOUT THE CO TWO
EMISSIONS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
THAT FACILITIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY. IT'S ABOUT THE TOXICS
AND THE HEALTH. HARMING
POLLUTANTS AND THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE FOCUSING ON
THOSE AND NOT ALLOWING THE. G.
HD PROGRAM JG PROGRAM TO BECOME
A TOOL BUT THESE COMPANIES CAN
USE TO INCREASE THEIR EMISSIONS
AND WE COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THAT WE DON'T THINK THAT. OUR
CURRENT PROGRAMS I JUST DID A TO
BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR WE DON'T
THINK THAT THE CURRENT PERMIT
PROGRAMS THAT THE DISTRICTS
OPERATE THAT WE HAVE. YOU KNOW
BEEN A PARTY TO ALL THESE YEARS.
ARE ADEQUATE BECAUSE WE
WOULDN'T BE SEEING THE LEVELS OF
EMISSIONS THAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO WE HAVE TO
FIND BETTER TOOLS TO TO DO IT.
BUT WE DON'T THINK OF THAT THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM ITSELF IS
A NECESSARILY EITHER THE CAUSE
OR THE CURE FOR. THAT PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
AND I KNOW PIGGYBACK ON A
LITTLE BIT OF A MISTER GARCIA
JUST.
TO SPOKE ABOUT.
EARLIER AND A POLY IN OUR AGO
WHEN ONE OF YOUR ANSWERS.
I.
IT WAS A CONVERSATION THAT HAD
BEEN STARTED BY MISS SKINNER.
ABOUT THE SCHOOL BEING PLANNED
AND YOU MADE THE STATEMENT THAT
THE SCOPING PLAN IS BUILDING ON.
PREVIOUS GOPI IMPLANTS.
THAT SHE WAS ASKING THAT WE
KNOW ARE WE LOOKING AT OTHER
INNOVATIVE WAYS IN THE
CONVERSATION REVOLVED AROUND
WATER SPECIFICALLY THERE BUT.
I I HAVE TO ASK THE SAME
QUESTION THOUGH IS THAT FAIR
WHEN WE'RE TALKING OF OUR MENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ABOUT
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BURDEN. TO
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THE SAME
TYPE OF FRAMEWORK THAT HAS LEFT
COMMUNITIES BEHIND COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE BEHIND. FOR A LONG
TIME AND SHOULD WE BE DOING
SURELY BE RELATE A LITTLE BIT
LESS ON.
CAP AND TRADE I KNOW IT'S NOT
THE FULL PORTFOLIO.
AND IN HERE RIGHT IT'S ABOUT.
FORTY SIX PERCENT BY WEIGHT SEMI
GET TO TWENTY THIRTY.
SUCH A BIG CHUNK BUT IT WAS ON
THE HOLDING I SHOULD ARE WE ARE
WE. ARE WE NOT.
WHY ARE WE DOING MORE INNOVATIVE
STE OF WHERE WE REALLY HAVE THIS
COMMITTEE'S COMMUNITIES TO LEAVE
WE MADE ENOUGH AND AB SIX
SEVENTEEN? WHILE I'M A PRODUCT
AUTHOR OF THAT DELICIOUS ONE
PIECE OF THE EQUATION IS NOT
GONNA SOLVE ALL OUR PROBLEMS
EITHER. NOT ALL COMMUNITIES ARE
GOING TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
SOUTH FOR AWHILE AS WE MOVE TO
DO ON AND SO FORTH AND SO WE
KNOW WHY WHY AREN'T WE THINKING
OUTSIDE THE BOX TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON HAVE. WHAT HAS FELT
LIKE YOU KNOW TRICKLE DOWN
ENVIRONMENTALISM THAT HAS AND
TRICKLE DOWN INTO HIS
COMMUNITIES SO?
?
WHAT I GO TO ADVANCE
AS WITH PEOPLE FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO COME TO VISIT US
OR EVEN WHEN I HAVE A HOME
TRAVELED AS I HAVE A COUPLE
TIMES AND? AS PART OF MY JOB TOO
INTERNATIONAL EVENTS FOR PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND I TALK TO THEM ABOUT WHAT
WE'VE DONE WITH INVESTING IN.
COMMUNITIES THAT PROCEEDS OF
OUR CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. NO
ONE HAS EVER HEARD OF ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BEFORE THEY DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND THE TERM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IS NOT I
MEAN THEY VAGUELY UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT MUST MEAN SOMETHING BUT.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE'VE ACTUALLY
WORK TO IDENTIFY AREAS AND THEN
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHO'S A SUBJECTED TO OF BOTH
THE. EXPECT CONCERNS ABOUT
POVERTY OR ISOLATION AND ALSO
OF.
IT BE LAYERING ON OF DIFFERENT
POLLUTANTS SOURCES.
AND THAT WE'RE USING OUR PROGRAM
AS A WAY TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
PEOPLE ARE FLABBERGASTED THE
IDEA HAS NEVER OCCURRED TO THAT
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY A SAY
THAT WERE SO BRILLIANT BUT WE
ARE DEFINITELY AHEAD OF.
OTHER PLACES AROUND THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF OUR THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO USE OUR CLIMATE PROGRAMS AS A
WAY TO ADDRESS INJUSTICES NOW.
THE MONEY THAT HAS COME THROUGH
OUR PROGRAM AND THAT HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED TO THE BUDGET.
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR HAS GONE TO A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS TWITTER
ONLY NOW. BEGINNING TO SHOW
THEIR A FAX BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM
IS STILL PRETTY NEW BUT WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE UNDER OUR BELTS. AND
PROBABLY SOME CORRECTIONS TO BE
MADE WHERE WE'RE SEEING
INVESTMENTS IN COMMUNITIES THAT
PEOPLE THINK ARE. HELPING TO
MOBILIZE OTHER INVESTMENTS AND
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH POLICIES
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY
TRY TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE AND HEALTH.
IN THE IN THE COMMUNITIES OF
CONCERNED SO I THINK I'M GOING
BACK TO SOME OF THE EARLIER
LEGISLATION.
ADDED CENTERED THAT. MONEY
BUSINESS ASSEMBLYMEMBER I GUESS
THAT I OWN THIS LEGISLATION IN
TERMS OF ALLOCATING SPECIFIC
PERCENTAGE OF THE FUNDS.
TO.
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND THAT POLICY DIRECTIVES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN.
I THINK YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OUR HELP US A AND
AND AND FOR ALL OF US TO LOOK
FOR. MORE CREATIVE WAYS TO ADD
TO DO GOOD MONEY IN AND OF
ITSELF ISN'T GOING TO SOLVE ALL
THE PROBLEMS BUT IT DEFINITELY
IS AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT. WHEN AND
THAT AS HIS FACE LOOK AT MORE
CREATIVE WAYS.
LOOKING AT THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR.
.
MORE AND AND WITH MORE URGENCY
IS IMPORTANT AND I. I PLAY
QUICKLY WITH THE MAPPING TOOL
VENUE PRESENTED THE VIDEO AND I
PULLED UP WITH MY DISTRICT SO.
UNDER THAT I HAD SIX FACILITIES
THAT ARE AFFECTED. INCOME TRADE
OF THE WHEN I LOOK AT MY MAP
IT'S ALL PRETTY BRIGHT RED AND
IT'S A SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR THAT
MOVES ALL THE GOOD FROM THE FOR
A LONG BEACH TO THE VALUE OUT OF
MY DISTRICT AND THEN ON TO THE
WAREHOUSES ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THAT ARE AFFECTING ME CLARITY
THAT TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS MY
BIGGER ISSUE ABILITIES SHE AND
OTHER POLLUTANTS OUT THERE AND
SO.
THIS OVER RELIANCE ON CAP AND
TRADE.
MIGHT WORK A WHOLE SYSTEM BUT
MAYBE MIGHT STILL CONTINUE TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE BEHIND.
AND SO I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
BE COGNIZANT OF THAT I DO THINK
IN SOME FAIRNESS AB SIX
SEVENTEEN WILL DRESS.
PART OF THIS ISSUE AND I I AM
ABSOLUTELY THE TO STOP US THE
OUT THERE BUT I ALSO KNOW ITS
LIMITATIONS AND FUNDING AND
ITSELF. BE ENOUGH AND SO.
AYE AYE DO YOU JUST ENCOURAGE
THAT WE WE THINK ABOUT
INNOVATIVE WHAT MORE INNOVATION
IN THAT SECTOR.
TYPICALLY AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
DO I HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WITH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THEN THAT MEANS WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SEX OF SECTION.
OF OUR HEARING. HAVE.
OKAY.
SO GO AHEAD AND AND OPEN IT UP
WE'VE. WE HAVE BEEN HERE FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS.
AND I DON'T WANT TO LIVE
EVOLVING PATIENT IN IN.
SPEAK BUT I WOULD ASK IF YOU CAN
TO BE MINDFUL OF THE TIME.
AND THAT WE HAVE HERE.
DO WE HAVE FOLKS I WANT COUPLE
GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE MIKE.
FOR ANYONE BLUNTLY ALMOST AT
ONCE.
I'VE NEVER SAID THAT IN A HURRY
BUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GARCIA AND
SHARE GARCIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY OF TO BE HERE MY
NAME IS DANNY COHEN WORD I'M A
RESEARCHER WITH THE NONPROFIT
NEAR ZERO AND ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE INDEPENDENT EMISSIONS MARKET
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT WAS SET
UP BY EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT.
A SPEAK TODAY JUST TODAY MY
PERSONAL CAPACITY.
WANNA MAKE A VERY BRIEF REMARK
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE SCOPING
PLAN BUILDING OFF WHAT DOCTOR
BROWN MENTIONED. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS TO KNOW THAT
THE WAY THE SCOPING PLAN
CALCULATES EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
IS BY PROJECTING THE TOTAL
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED. THAN
TAKING A LOOK AT THE SPECIFIC
REGULATORY ACTIONS THINGS LIKE
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD A
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
THAT ARE REASONABLY WELL
QUANTIFIED. AND THEN ESTIMATING
THE IMPACTS OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
THE GAP BETWEEN THAT AND THE
TARGET IS LEFT TO CAP AND TRADE.
THERE IS NO ANALYSIS IN THE
SCOPING PLAN. OF WHAT MARKET
DESIGNED FOR CAP AND TRADE IS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THOSE
OUTCOMES NO ANALYSIS.
IN THIS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDER BECAUSE AS MANY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
TO COMMITTEES OF MENTION TODAY
CAP AND TRADE IS THE SINGLE
LARGEST PIECE OF THE SCOPING
PLAN IT'S THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT
OF THE CUMULATIVE PRODUCTIONS
THAT ARE BECAUSE FOR OVER THE
NEXT DECADE AND IT'S ABOUT FORTY
FIVE OR FORTY SIX PERCENT. OF
THE REDUCTIONS AIR BECAUSE FOR
IN TWENTY THIRTY THAT IS A VERY
LARGE AND SIGNIFICANT COMPONENT.
BUT THERE'S NO ANALYSIS OF HOW
THAT PROGRAM WILL DELIVER ON THE
GOAL THAT AIR BE HAS STATED FOR
IT. THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO MONITORING TO WATCH
GOING FORWARD I'M MINDFUL ALSO
THAT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD WAS
COMPELLED BY EIGHTY THREE NINETY
EIGHT TO FINISH IT SCOPING PLAN
LAST MONTH. WELL IN ADVANCE OF
THE AB THREE NINETY EIGHT
REGULATIONS BUT I THINK IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT TO SEE
CONSISTENCY BETWEEN THOSE TWO
PROCESSES SO THAT THIS PROGRAM.
WHATEVER FLAWS VERY STAKEHOLDER
SEEN THE PROGRAM DELIVERS ON THE
COMPONENT THAT AREAS CALLED FOR
AGAIN THE SINGLE LARGEST
COMPONENT. OF OUR CLIMATE PLAN
ISN'T CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ANNA
VASQUEZ I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ROOM TO JUST
ALLIANCE. AND RUN ALLIANCE A
REPRESENTS TEN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WANNA THINKS AT LEAST
I WITH SO HIGH WE HAVE.
CLOSELY FOLLOWED THIS ISSUE FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS AND WE WERE
ACTUALLY AT THE BOARD MEETING
LAST DECEMBER AND ONE OF THINGS
THAT WE SAW IS REALLY CALLING
CAP AND TRADE AS A DIRECT
EMISSIONS REDUCTION MEASURE. AND
FOR US IS A LITTLE BIT
PROBLEMATIC GIVEN THAT IT DOES
GIVE US DIRECT EMISSIONS BUT IS
NOT A MEASURE THAT GIVES US A.
DIRECT EMISSIONS AT THE SOURCE
AND SPECIFICALLY AT THE FACILITY
SOURCES WERE A LOT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ORGANIZATIONS
ARE BASE OUT. HE WANTED THINGS
AS MENTIONED BIAS MEMBER GARCIA
IS HOW DO WE SEE IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB ONE NINETY SEVEN INCOME IN
ON COMPLEMENT AND REALLY
COMPLIMENTING CAP AND TRADE. AND
I REALLY REPLACING AN AND FOR US
IS REALLY SEEN THOSE REDUCTIONS
WERE LARGE CESSATION SOURCES ARE
LOCATED SPECIFICALLY ALSO MOBILE
FORCES AND REALLY GETTING A
SENSE OF WHAT MOST PEOPLE. OF
WHAT ARE THE MOBILE FORCES
REDUCTIONS OF RELEASED FROM TO
SEE. TO REALLY MEET OUR TWENTY
THIRTY TARGETS BUT ALSO LOOKING
AT HOW AB ONE. I'M SIX ONE SEVEN
SIX ONE SEVEN.
CAN ACTUALLY COMPLEMENT THE CAP
AND TRADE A REDUCTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY.
INSIST TODAY WITH REDUCTIONS
THAT WE SEE CURRENTLY THE
SCOPING PLAN BUT IT'S NOT
REPLACING IT BECAUSE SIX ONE
SEVEN IT IS SOMETHING THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE UTILIZING BUT
IT'S NOT GONNA BE THE ONE FIXING
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE. THAT
VOCALIZE POLLUTION MONIES TO BE
ADDRESSED SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
CRITERIA.
ISSUE THAT WE MOVING FORWARD AND
REALLY
WORKING.
WITH CARVE STAFF AND REALLY
LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES AND WE
REALLY HOPE AND THE NEXT ON
COUPLE MONTHS AND NEXT YEAR WE
CAN ACTUALLY FINALIZE.
POSTSCRIPT UPON THAT CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A SOME BUT IT
PRODUCTIONS THAT WE REALLY WANT
TO SEE.
FOR US NUMBER ONE AT THE SOURCE
BUT ALSO TO IS REALLY GETTING A
TRANSPARENT SEN THE TRANSPARENCY
OF HOW ARE THESE.
ADMISSIONS GOING TO BE DONE AND.
IN WHAT TIMEFRAME FOR US TO GET
A SENSE OF HOW DO WE COMMUNICATE
THIS THESE ISSUES IN THESE.
EFFORTS TO OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SO THANK YOU.
DEAR COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
RECENTLY RETURNED FROM A YEAR
AND A HALF WORKING IN MEXICO'S
MINISTER THE ENVIRONMENT HAVING
THEM FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEVELOP A
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM. LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S
ONE OF THE MAIN STICKING POINTS
THERE IS THAT GASOLINE PRICES
BOARD ALSO
REDUCE EMISSIONS.
I'M PERSONALLY NOT AGAINST
INCREASE IN GASOLINE PRICES BUT
WE SHOULD BE CLEAR TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS WHAT IT ACTUALLY MEANS
WHEN YOU'RE GONNA JUST CAPS
AGAIN.
A RECENT PUBLICATION BY UC DAVIS
UC BERKELEY AND STANFORD
ECONOMISTS SAID THAT YOU WOULD
PROBABLY GET ABOUT FOUR MILLION
EXTRA TONS REDUCTION INDUCED PER
YEAR. BY CHANGING THE CAPS.
AND THAT'S NOT NOTHING BUT IS
COMPARED TO THE THIRTY SIX
BILLION TONS OF EMISSIONS
WORLDWIDE IT IS ALMOST NOTHING.
NOW THIS GETS MY POINT UP FINAL
POINT.
WHICH IS IF WE KEEP MESSING WITH
THIS PROGRAM.
IT GETS MORE EXPENSIVE AND MORE
COMPLICATED AND OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WILL NOT WANT TO
FOLLOW OUR LEAD.
CALIFORNIA CANCEL CLIMATE CHANGE
ON ITS OWN BECAUSE WE REPRESENT
ONLY ONE PERCENT OF GLOBAL
EMISSIONS.
AND IF WE'RE NOT INSPIRING OTHER
JURISDICTIONS TO FOLLOW US THEN
THESE EFFORTS WILL BE FOR NOT.
AS WE DEBATE THE FINER DE
DETAILS OF CAP AND TRADE. THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS BUILDING
WALLS AND.
DISMANTLING OBAMA'S EFFORTS TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS.
SO THINK ABOUT HOW TO MAKE THIS
PROGRAM MORE INCLUSIVE AND OPEN
RATHER THAN MORE ISOLATIONIST.
I'M JOHN DONVAN REPRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL EMISSIONS TRADING
ASSOCIATION AND THIS IS MY
TESTIMONY.
IN.
HI AS GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
NEEDED BEFORE THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS WE
REPRESENT THE RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS INDUSTRY IN NORTH AMERICA. I
LIKE TO BRIEFLY THINK CHAIRMAN
ECHOES AND HER STAFF
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFYING THE
DEVELOPMENT AND UTILIZATION OF
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AS KEY
STRATEGIES IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR
THE MEMBERS THREE EXCERPTS FROM
THE SCOPING PLAN THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. AT ONE REPLACING
FOX A FEW AUTHORED RENEWABLE GAS
CAN REDUCE POTENT CHART THE
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS AND STATE
POLICY SHOULD SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT. MOVING TOWARDS RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
ACHIEVE ITS TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE TARGET.
TWO AS WE LOOK TO REDUCE OVERALL
METHANE EMISSIONS WE MUST ALSO
INCLUDE THE RECOVERY OF METHANE
FROM LANDFILLS LIVESTOCK
OPERATIONS AND WE START
TREATMENT FACILITIES.
AND THREE WE MUST MOVE TOWARD
CLEANER FOSSIL R. CLEANER FUELS
AND FOR SPACE AND WATER HEATING.
WHICH INCLUDES RIVER USING MARIN
OVER GAS A VALUABLE INSTANT
RESOURCE MADE FROM WASTE
PRODUCTS ESPECIALLY IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEIR RESOURCES BOARD AND
LEGISLATURE TO.
INCREASE THE DEVELOPMENT AND
UTILIZATION OF RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS
TO HELP IMPLEMENT DESCRIBING
PLAN AND IT'S.
VISION OF STATE POLICIES THAT.
.
IS ADVISE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND STATE
THINK IF.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ON MY
NAME IS RYAN KENNY WITH CLEAN
ENERGY.
REALLY NATION'S LARGEST PROVIDER
OF RENEWABLE NOW TO GAS
TRANSPORTATION FEEL. WE HAVE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE AYE STATIONS
ALONG HERE IN CALIFORNIA ALSO
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF OUR FUEL IS MADE FROM
RENEWABLE SOURCES I WANTED TO
OUR BRAVE A FEW POINTS THAT WILL
I'M. BEACH YOU.
EVENTUALLY THROUGH THE F.
FISCAL IMPACTS.
WE WERE VERY SUPPORT OF THE
SCOPING PLAN AND HOW THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS IN STRATEGIES IN IT BUT
AS YOU KNOW THAT THE DEVIL'S
ALWAYS THE DETAILS. AND OUT FOR
INSTANCE.
THE MOBILE THE MOBILE SOURCE
STRATEGY DOCUMENT DOES CALL FOR
NINE TWO THOUSAND LOW KNOCKS
VEHICLES TO MEET FEDERAL KNOCKS
PAYMENT BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY ONE.
AND.
CENTER SKINNER BROUGHT KNOCKS
EARLIER AND.
WHILE THAT'S A THE GOAL THAT
TODAY AIR BE IN CYCLE TO SHARE
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A GAP BETWEEN
THE GOAL AND WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING SO WE DO ENCOURAGE
HAVE FURTHER FUNDING.
FOR.
LOW KNOCKS VEHICLES.
GOING FORWARD WITH IN ANY THE
JEEZ YOU'RE OFF A FUNDING PLAN
FOR THIS YEAR AND SO FORTH.
ALSO WITH THE MOBILE SOURCE
STRATEGY DOCUMENTED DOES.
OFFER TO INCREASE AS YOUR
MISSION BUSES
AND A RIGHT NOW YOU'RE BE IS AYE
AYE GO AND GO AND I'LL FIVE
WORKSHOPS THUS FAR. ON THE
INTERVIEW THE CLEAN TRANSIT
PROGRAM TO AYE MANDATE ZERO
EMISSION BUSES.
AND. I WILL SPEAK THE TRANSIT
INDUSTRY BUT THERE WAS AYE
SUBSTANTIAL CONCERN WITHIN THE
WORKSHOPS OF THE COSTS
AS WELL AS A LACK OF INCENTIVES.
AND THAT'S WHERE I YOU'LL COME
INTO PLAY OBVIOUSLY FOR POSSIBLY
MORE INCENTIVE FUNDING.
ZERO EMISSION BUSES COST UP TO
FIVE TIMES AS MUCH AS LOW NOTS
BUSES AND THE ONLY.
LESSON ONE PERCENT CLEANER.
LOW KNOCKS BUSES OFTENTIMES NINE
NINE PERCENT CLEANER THEN I
DIESEL.
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES.
WE NEEDED YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
HOW IT IMPACT THE LTFS
AND A FORCING A TECHNOLOGY.
WHICH PICKED WHICH PICKS WINNERS
AND LOSERS IN NOT HAVING A
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS HIP
POINTED TO KNOX WILL IMPACT
OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN THAT THE
SCOPING PLAN. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID WEISKOPF I'M
WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE.
CHAIR NICHOLS IN THE AIR BE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK HAS GONE
INTO THIS EFFORT SO FAR.
WE OF COURSE.
IN CALIFORNIA COME FARTHER
FASTER THAN ANY ITS JURISDICTION
EXCUSE ME THAN ANY OTHER
JURISDICTION THAT ATTEMPTED TO.
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE I'D JUST
LIKE US TO KEEP IN MIND THAT.
NOT ONLY SHOULD WE BE FOCUSING
ON WHERE WE'VE COME FROM BUT
ALSO WHERE WE NEED TO GET TO
WHERE SCIENCE TELLS US WE NEED
TO GET TO. AS THE URGENCY OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS CONTINUING TO
INCREASE AS WE'RE HAVING
UNEXPECTED EVENTS LIKE THE WILD
FIRES THAT WE'VE SEEN THIS YEAR.
WE MUST THINK ABOUT EVERY
DECISION NOT JUST LARGE SCALE
BUT SMALL SCALE. R. MATTERS
WHERE WE HAVE POLICY DISCRETION
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
DISCRETION.
AND ASK OURSELVES WHETHER THIS
IS HELPING US TO ACCELERATE TO
KEEP UP WITH THE INCREASING
URGENCY THAT SCIENCE IS TELLING
US.
OR WHETHER IT'S SLOWING US DOWN
MAY THINK THAT PERTAINS TO
ISSUES RELATED TO.
THE CARBON MARKET DESIGN THE
CEILING PRICE.
SPEED BUMPS.
WHAT TO DO WITH THE OVERHANG
ALLOWANCES AND ALSO WHAT TO DO
WITH COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES SUCH
AS LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
CLEAN CARS INITIATIVES AND SO
ON?
AND SO I THINK. FOCUSING ON ANY
INDIVIDUAL POLICY SAYING THIS
AFFECT MAYBE SMALL SMALL
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA RELATIVE
TO GLOBAL.
IS.
A DANGEROUS PATH TO GO DOWN WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON THE OVERALL
PHILOSOPHICAL POSITION. SHOULD
WE BE MAKING CHOICES WITH A VIEW
TO ACCELERATING OUR EFFORTS OR
WITH A VIEW TOWARDS.
KEEPING COSTS LOW.
IT POTENTIALLY AT THE RISK OF
SLOWING OUR EFFORTS NOW THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JASON VARGAS WITH
THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS COUPLE JUST BRIEF
COMMENTS ONE.
IT'S VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE.
CONVERSATION TODAY ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF BANK
ALLOWANCES IN THE CAP AND TRADE
SYSTEM. ON OUR ABILITY TO MEET
OUR TWENTY THIRTY.
CLIMATE CHANGE LIMIT.
AND.
WE AGREE THAT IT'S A AN ISSUE
THAT DESERVES.
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION AND
INVESTIGATION AND A POTENTIALLY
FURTHER ACTION.
TO ENSURE THAT WE REACH OUR
STATUTORY. LIMITS ESTABLISHED BY
S. B. THIRTY TWO.
.
IN GENERAL VERY SUPPORTIVE
THAT'S GOING PLAN WAS ADOPTED A
COUPLE THINGS ON HIS FLAG THAT
WE RATE IN OUR RECENT COMMENTS
TO CARVE.
ON THE PLAN ONE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SEEN
STRONGER COMMITMENTS AROUND
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION
BUILDING THE CARBONIZATION.
I'M CENTER SKINNER BROUGHT IT UP
BRIEFLY TODAY AND I THINK THAT'S
AN AREA THAT. I MIGHT EVERY
COMMITTEES MIGHT BE JUST DIDN'T
IN EXPLORING FURTHER. ON AND
THEN ON ON VEHICLE EXTRICATION
THERE'S OF COURSE A LOT OF THE
STATE AND HAS DOING IS COMMITTED
TO AND THAT'S EMBODIED IN THE
SCOPING PLAN.
ONE AREA WHERE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SING GREATER COMMITMENT WAS ON
ELECTRIFICATION OF DRAINAGE
TRUCKS.
AND AND.
COMMITMENT IS SOME TYPE OF
REGULATORY ACTION.
DON'T THINK YOU OUGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BONNIE HOMES GEM
OF THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA. AND THE LUNG
ASSOCIATION OF SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SCOPING PLAN IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD.
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA'S.
LEADERSHIP ON CLIMATE AND THE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD TO IMPROVE
AIR QUALITY IN HEALTH AND TO
LEAD CLIMB EFFORTS AROUND THE
GLOBE.
WE'RE VERY PLEASED THIS PLAN
INCLUDES A STRONG MULTI
POLLUTANT FOCUS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SAGA EDUARDO AND
CHRISTINA GARCIA THANK YOU FOR
STRENGTHENING THIS FOCUS THROUGH
YOUR LEGISLATION AB WHEN I SEVEN
AB.
A SIX ONE SEVEN.
AS WHAT IS YOUR THREE COMMENTS
THAT WE'VE OP SHARED WITH THE
BOARD LAST MONTH. BONTA STRENGTH
OUR EFFORTS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AND ONE IS THAT WE WANT TO.
TO MOVE FORWARD RAPIDLY TO
COMPLETE A COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
EVALUATION AS ANOTHER COMPONENT
OF THE SCOPING PLAN.
TO INCLUDE A BROADER ANALYSIS
THAT COULD BE INCLUDED IN THIS
CURRENT DOCUMENT WE APPRECIATE
THAT WAS SOME LANGUAGE IN THE
RESOLUTION AND THERE'S AN INTENT
TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND I CONDUCT THIS BROADER
HEALTH EVALUATION SO THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP.
WE ALSO SEE THE IMPORTANCE OF
STRENGTHENING THE S. B. THREE
SEVENTY FIVE IN THE. A
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES
COMPONENT OF THE PLAN IS MORE WE
CAN DO IN THAT AREA.
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
A CONTINUED PUSH FOR DEEPER
REDUCTIONS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT TODAY WITH MORE
ELECTRIFICATION MORE FOCUS ON
LIKE APPLICATION THE HEAVY DUTY
SECTOR. INCREASE THE ANTE
REDUCTION.
AND HIGHER CARBON INTENSITY
REDUCTION TARGETS FOR THE LOW
CARBON FEEL CENTERED BEYOND THE
TWENTY PERCENT. REDUCTION.
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN THE PLAN
AND WE OF COURSE.
SUPPORT CONTINUED FOCUS ON
PRIORITIZING DIRECT EMISSION
REDUCTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I'M CAITLIN
JENNER CENTER WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE JUST A
COUPLE OF BRIEF COMMENTS.
AND THE FIRST I I REALLY WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IS WORKING AND IT'S
DOING WHAT IT WAS INTENDED TO
DO.
IT IS THE BACKSTOPS THAT
INSURERS CALIFORNIA WILL MEET
OUR CLIMATE TARGETS.
AND AND IT'S DOING THAT.
CARBON EMISSIONS ARE DECREASING
AND WERE AHEAD OF SCHEDULE TO
MEET OUR TWENTY TWENTY TARGET.
EVEN WHILE WE'VE SEEN ROBUST
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
AT THE SAME TIME WE CERTAINLY
RECOMMEND THAT MORE CAN AND
SHOULD BE DONE TO ADDRESS LOCAL
AIR QUALITY AND TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS. THROUGH TOOLS
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES.
AND THE SCOPING PLAN IS ABOUT
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
PROGRAMS AND TOOLS THAT WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS A NUMBER OF
CLIMATE AND AIR QUALITY ISSUES.
CAP AND TRADE ISN'T THE ONLY
PLAYER.
ON THAT TEAM. PROGRAMS LIKE THE
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD IN
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
HAVE AN IMPORTANT AND DIFFERENT
ROLE TO PLAY ON THAT TEAM IN
MEETING OUR TWENTY THIRTY
TARGET.
AND DECREASING EMISSIONS
ESPECIALLY TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS.
BUT AGAIN WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE
CAN AND SHOULD DO MORE.
ON TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
AND AND THE LAST POINT I JUST
WANTED TO REFERENCE BACK TO
CHAIR NICHOLS COMMENT AND AND
AND WE AGREE WITH THE ASSESSMENT
FROM FROM HER AND FROM CARVE
THAT. CAP AND TRADE WILL DRIVE
DIRECT EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND
IN FACT WE HAVE SEEN NOW BUT IT
IS NOT A DIRECT MEASURE. AND SO
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT DISTINCTION
WE THINK IN LIGHT OF AB ONE
NINETY SEVEN AND DOESN'T
UNDERMINE THE IMPORTANT PURPOSE
OF AB ONE NINETY SEVEN. AND SO
WE JUST WANTED TO TO ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND THE SCOPING PLAN FOR
YOUR ANALYSIS AND THANKS FOR
PUTTING THIS HEARING TOGETHER
TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN AROUND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE FOOD
PRODUCERS AYE AYE CONKLIN
WHETHER NOT I SHOULD SPEAK BUT.
IN TALKING ABOUT THE CAP AND
TRADE IS IS PUBLIC CENTRAL TO US
AS MOST OF OUR MEMBERS WE HAVE
TWENTY ONE MEMBERS WHO ARE
SUBJECT TO A CAP AND TRADE
ITSELF AND HAVE A COMPLAINTS
OBLIGATION EACH AND EVERY YEAR.
.
WHEN AB THIRTY TO FIRST START OF
THE CAP AND TRADE WAS CONSIDERED
A LEAKAGE PREVENTION. PROGRAM.
IT WAS DESIGNED TO ALLOW
COMPANIES WHO WERE SUBJECT THE
CAP AND TRADE TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THE COMPLIANCE OBLIGATIONS. IN
THE LEAST COST MANNER WHILE WE
WERE WAITING FOR TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WE COULD THEN. INCORPORATE
INTO OUR FACILITIES TACTIC THEN
NOT HAVE TO BUY THOSE ALLOWANCES
AND BECOME MORE EFFICIENT.
.
THE TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPMENT HAS
BEEN VERY VERY SLOW AND.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MEET OUR
TWENTY THIRTY GOALS WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO INCREASE THAT IN
ORDER TO ALLOW THOSE COMPANIES
TO BE ABLE TO TO MEET THOSE
THOSE OBLIGATIONS.
BECAUSE IN THE END.
CAP AND TRADE IS NOT AS AS
MISTER KHtNG WORDS AND.
CAP AND TRADE IS CENTRAL TO THIS
AND IT'S THE BIGGEST PART OF OF
OUR ENTIRE.
GOALS PROCESS HERE HOWEVER IT'S
ALSO THE BACKSTOPS.
IN FOR ALL THE OTHER
COMPLEMENTARY MEASURES YOU SEE
AND NOW LIST.
ANY OF THEM THAT FAIL TO MEET
THEIR REDUCTION GOALS FALLS ON
CAP AND TRADE FACILITIES.
THAT MEANS IT'S NOT JUST THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT IT COULD BE FORTY
PERCENT IT COULD BE FIFTY
PERCENT IT COULD BE SIXTY
PERCENT COULD BE BIGGER.
AND THAT'S GOING TO REALLY
AFFECT OUR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO BE COMPETITIVE.
IF THAT'S THE CASE.
SO.
I AM URGING RIGHT NOW AS I'VE
ALWAYS HAVE IS THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY INCREASE.
A FUNDING IN. RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE.
FACILITIES LOCATED IN THE CAP
AND TRADE.
BY THE WAY ON DIRECT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS UNDER THE CAP AND
TRADE. ANYTIME A FACILITY LIKE
OURS IS ABLE TO RECEIVE MONEY
FROM THE CAP AND TRADE AND TO
PARLAY THAT INTO A RETROFIT OR A
NEW BOILER OR SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES. THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE
DIRECT REDUCTION.
AND IT'S IN AREAS THAT ARE ARE
SUBJECT TO THE IN WHEN VIRAL
SCREEN FOR FOR LOW INCOME AREAS
SO THERE'S WAYS TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN BUT WE REALLY HAVE TO
START THINKING IN TERMS OF. OF
NOT JUST WHAT CAN WE DO BUT HOW
CAN WE DO IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR FACILITIES CONTINUE TO
OPERATE. AND AND THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE RECEIVED ARE TO MEET
OUR REDUCTION GOALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
SPEAK THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRUCE RAY AND WITH JOHNS
MANVILLE.
WE'RE BERKSHIRE HATHAWAY
COMPANY OF FOCUSING ON THE
MANUFACTURE OF.
VARIOUS
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PRODUCTS
INCLUDING INSULATION MANY FORMS
OF INSULATION FOR DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS WE HAVE ONE OF OUR
NORTH AMERICAN FLAGSHIP
MANUFACTURING LOCATIONS ABOUT AN
HOUR NORTH OF HERE. IN WILLOW'S
SIDE INCLINED COUNTY.
WHERE THREE HUNDRED OF OUR
EMPLOYEES MAKE?
A FIRE GLASS BUILDING
INSULATION AND SINCE WE HAD
DOESN'T DISCUSSION CONCERNING A
LARGE FACILITY EMISSIONS I WOULD
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T MENTION
THAT.
YEARS AGO JOHN SMITH BILL
INVESTED IN A VERY.
LOW WIND SHEAR LOW CARB AND LOW
EMITTING PROCESS.
TO MAKE OUR INSULATION AND WHEN
WE SWITCHED TO A FORMALDEHYDE
FREE.
BINDER SOME YEARS AGO WE ALSO
REDUCED OUR HAZARDOUS AIR
POLLUTANTS.
HAS ITS AIR POLLUTION.
EMISSIONS BY NINETY NINE
PERCENT.
IT IF YOU LOOK AT THE UPDATED
SCOPING PLAN.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY IS GOING TO
BE CALLED UPON TO ACHIEVE AROUND
TEN PERCENT OF CUMULATIVE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS.
AND THAT'S THAT'S ACTUALLY MORE
THAN DOUBLE OF WHAT.
I THINK THE EVEN FIFTY PERCENT
ARE PSS IS I'M GOING TO BE
CALLED ON FOR.
IF I COULD MAKE A.
ONE RECOMMENDATION ON HOW
ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN THE ON THAT
PART OF IT AND THAT IS THAT
THERE ARE LITERALLY MILLIONS OF
UNDER INSULATED HOMES. IN THE
STATE MIDI THEM VERY POOR
PERFORMERS FROM A AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY STANDPOINT. AND.
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
IF NOT MILLIONS OF THEM WILL
NEED TO BE RETROFITTED. IN ORDER
FOR THE STATE TO ACHIEVE ITS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS NOW THERE THERE
ARE SOME CAP AND TREATMENT IS
THAT EARMARKED FOR
WEATHERIZATION BUT IT JUST GOES
TO THE EXISTING. LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
IF I GET AGAIN MAKE ONE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATION HOPING THAT THE
STATE MIGHT CONSIDER. A LITTLE
BIT OF AN ALTERNATIVE COURSE IN
THIS IS.
AYE TO DO A RETROFIT.
IT RESIDENTIAL RETROFITS.
AND ALONG THE LINES OF.
WHAT JOHNS MANVILLE
PARTICIPATED IN ENOUGH A BIG
PROJECT AND NOW THE COACHELLA
VALLEY?
A MEMBER GARCIA IN YOUR IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
ALONG WITH THE US SOUTH COAST
OR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
WE PROVIDED BASIC ENERGY
EFFICIENCY RETROFITS TO A TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED HOMES IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AREA AND
FOCUSED ON THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
DOWN THERE AND WE WERE ABLE TO.
QUANTIFY NOT ONLY THE ENERGY
SAVINGS BUT ALSO THE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS IN TERMS OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND.
PARTICULATE TO FINE PARTICULATE
EMISSIONS.
SO.
AND AND THEN ALSO YOU GET THE
CO BENEFIT OF INCREASED HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF FOR THE.
FOR THE HOMEOWNERS AND HOME
OCCUPANT SO. AND.
AND I I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY INVITE.
ANY MEMBERS WHO WOULD BE
INTERESTED TO COME UP AND TO OUR
FACILITY.
I'D SAY IF YOU'VE NEVER SEEN A
FIVE PLUS INSULATION BE MADE
ITSELF.
IT'S PRETTY INTERESTING PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY MICHAEL BROKERED R.
ON BEHALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION. WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP ON A FEW OF THE POINTS
THAT WERE MADE BY A CHAIR
NICHOLS AND THE QUESTIONS FROM.
.
SENATOR SKINNER AND OTHER
COMMENTS EARLIER FROM A COUPLE
OF WITNESSES ON RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
QUESTION AND DIRECT RESPONSE TO
THE SCANNERS QUESTION THAT WE
NEED TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF NATURAL GAS BEING USED
IN THE STATE PARTICULARLY IN OUR
HOMES FOR HEATING.
FOR.
OTHER PURPOSES I WATER HEATERS
AND OTHERS THAT'S GONNA NEED TO
BE PART OF THE STRATEGY.
THERE ARE SOME WHO ARE GOING TO
TRY AND CONVINCE YOU THIS YEAR
THAT YOU CAN REPLACE ALL THAT
WITH A. RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AS
A REPLACEMENT FEEL IT'S JUST
SIMPLY NOT TRUE IT WAS
CONSIDERED BY AIR BE A FIVE
PERCENT RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
STANDARD.
BUT WASN'T.
SPOKEN OF EARLIER IN TERMS OF.
SOME OF THE FINDINGS OF THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WAS THE COST OF
THAT RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
STANDARD IN CALIFORNIA.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER TON OF
EMISSIONS REDUCTION.
THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN
THE SCOPING PLAN AND WHY ITS NOT
A GOOD SOLUTION FOR THE STATE WE
CAN'T AFFORD RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS IN THE INDUSTRIAL SECTOR IN
THE FOOD PROCESSORS THAT
REPRESENT.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME THAT
ONE OF FORCE THAT UPON US SO BE
VERY CAUTIOUS AS WE HAVE THIS
DEBATE AND WE TALK ABOUT
RENEWABLE GAS.
WHAT DOES MAKE SENSE IS THAT WE
CAPTURE RENEWABLE GAS?
FROM LANDFILLS FROM WASTE WATER
AGENCIES IN FROM DAIRIES BECAUSE
THAT MAKES A TON OF SENSE THAT'S
FUGITIVE METHANE. WE NEED TO
CAPTURE THAT PUT THAT TO USE
PROBABLY MOSTLY AS
TRANSPORTATION FEE ON THE STATE.
MAKES A TON A SENSE WHAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE IS GOING BEYOND THAT
AND THAT'S WHERE THERE ARE SOME
FOLKS THAT WANNA STAY AHEAD IN
THE STATE. AND I JUST WANT TO
WARN YOU BE WARY BECAUSE THAT'S
A VERY EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION
THINK.
HI TIME TO KILL SO VILE HERE WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENT ACCOUNT BALANCE.
.
JUST WANTED A.
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIRS FOR
ALL THESE COMMITTEE HEARING.
HOPEFULLY OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEARS THROUGH THESE HEARINGS
AND THROUGH OTHER STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS IS THAT THERE BE A. SOME
OF THE.
COME MORE TECHNICAL ISSUES ARE
ARE CLARIFIED FOR THE PUBLIC WE
SPUR STILL SING A LOT THAT WE
SIDE TODAY. I'M WERE JUMPING IN
AND OUT OF OF POLICIES AND BACK
AND FORTH THROUGH TIME LINES AND
AND CREATING A AN UNCLEAR
PICTURE THAT THAT THE PUBLIC.
AND EVEN SOME COMPLIANCE
ENTITIES AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
CAN'T CLARIFY ON THEIR OWN I
THINK CHAIR NICHOLS DID A GOOD
JOB AT. THAT CREATING SOME
CLARITY AND DEFINITION AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN CONTINUE
THAT IT IT IS IMPORTANT BE
FAIRLY PRECISE IN YOUR LANGUAGE.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CAP
AND TRADE CAP VERSES THE SCOPING
PLANNED CAPPER THE S. B. THIRTY
TWO GOALS THAT THEY ARE
DIFFERENT THINGS YES THEY'RE
WORKING TOWARDS THE SAME AND BUT
BUT THEY'RE DIFFERENT PIECES OF
A PUZZLE. I'M ALSO LOCAL STATE
AND FEDERAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT OF LONG
STANDING. HISTORY AND HOW THOSE
LINES ARE DRAWN AND HOW THOSE
THINGS WORK IN AND YOU KNOW AS
WE. EXAMINE THESE THINGS THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO TO SEE IF
THOSE LINES ARE THE LINES SHOULD
BE DRAWN OR IF THEY'RE WORKING
AS PROPERLY. AS I THINK SOME OF
THE CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD MAYBE
THAT THESE LINES ARE BLURRED AND
I NEED TO BE CLARIFIED IT MAYBE
LINES ARE DRAWN IN THE WRONG
SPOT. AND I HOPE THAT THAT WE
CAN KIND OF KEEP.
YOU KNOW THE FOCUS ON ON WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AT EACH
AND EVERY MOMENT SO.
WILL PROBABLY FOLLOW UP WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO THE
TO THE COMMITTEE BUT WE
APPRECIATE THAT HAPPENS LIKE.
HELLO VALERIE TRAIL OF BLACK
HOSE SPECIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY I'M ALSO WANNA THINK
THOUGH THE CHAIRS IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEES
FOR HOLDING THIS I'M HEARING
TODAY. AND.
JUST WHERE TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS OF WE HEARD FROM OUR
WITH THE WITNESSES TODAY THAT
THERE IS A DELICATE BALANCE.
TO BE STRUCK.
.
BETWEEN OUR CARBON ALLOWANCE
PRICES.
AND THAT THAT ARE HIGH ENOUGH TO
DRIVE THE REDUCTIONS THAT WE
NEED AND THE BUSINESS DECISIONS.
THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE AND PRICES
THAT CAN. GET SOHIGH THAT THEY
THREATEN OUR ECONOMIC VITALITY
AND YOU HEARD THIS ALL LAST
YEAR.
IN THE YOU KNOW AB THREE NINETY
EIGHT.
DEBATE AND P. GINNY'S COME TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT THAT THROUGH
ALL OF THE ANALYSIS AND.
STUDIES THAT THE SCOPING PLAN
DOES A GREAT JOB AND BALANCE
MAKING DOING THIS BALANCING ACT.
SO.
WE JUST WANTED TO.
AND THAT'S WITH OUTSIDE
CONSULTANTS AND EXPERTS EXCEPT
TRACK SO.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO ECHO A
COMMENT MADE BY A. PREVIOUS AYE
WITNESS HERE AND PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
STATE WHY CAP. IS FIRM.
AND SIGNIFICANTLY STRICT WITH A
GETS VERY AGGRESSIVE TO ACHIEVE
THAT GOAL ON EVEN IF BANKING
ALLOWS ENTITIES.
TO EXCEED.
THAT CAP IN A GIVEN YEAR THE
CAP IS UP STATEWIDE AND NOT ON
INDIVIDUAL ENTITIES OR
INDUSTRIES.
THAT'S THE ELEGANCE OF ON THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
FINALLY I JUST WANNA KNOW THAT
P. GENIE IS COMMITTED TO D.
CARBON AYE SAYING.
IT'S NATURAL GAS SYSTEM AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
AND WORKING WITH.
ACT HARD AS WE IMPLEMENT AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT AND THE PRICE
CAP.
AB PROCEEDINGS THAT WILL TAKE
PLACE THIS YEAR IN A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER THINK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TIM CARMICHAEL WAS
SEPARATE UTILITIES AS THE PARENT
COMPANY OF US ANY GOOD GAS
ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS COMPANY.
ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT OF VALOR
TRAILER JUST MADE ON BEHALF OF
P. GENIE BUT I WON AT THREE
POINTS.
ONE.
.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD ADOPTED
MAJOR CHANGES TO THEIR A CLIMATE
STRATEGY IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WITH A LOT OF INPUT FROM
THE LEGISLATURE.
IT'S A LOAN IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THAT PLAN IS NOT
STATIC IT'S NOT LOCKED IN FOR
LIFE.
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT THAT THAT
IT BE UPDATED AT LEAST EVERY
FIVE YEARS AND. WE. ARE LEARNING
EVERY YEAR WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S
NOT WORKING THE ENHANCEMENTS
THAT CAME FROM LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR ABOUT ADDITIONAL. ON
MONITORING REQUIREMENTS ARE
GONNA MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
GOING FORWARD AND INFORMING WHAT
STRATEGIES ARE ARE AFFECTED AND
WHAT WHICH ONES WE NEED TO
IMPROVE.
.
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PLAN THAT'S IN AND PLACE.
SECOND POINT.
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH MR
BROKEN DOORS COMMENTS WE AGREE
ABSOLUTELY ON THE NEED TO
CAPTURE FUGITIVE METHANE IN THE
STATE AND THERE'S TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT. WHERE WE
DISAGREE IS THAT WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE LOW CARB JUST
IN OUR PROGRAM IS ENOUGH TO
INCENTIVIZE THE DEVELOPMENT THAT
WE NEED TO SEE IN CALIFORNIA
RELATED TO NO ONE NATURAL GAS?
SO WE ARE GOING TO BE ADVOCATING
FOR THE ADDITIONAL EFFORTS.
TO ENCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT
AND USE OF RENEWABLE GAS IN
CALIFORNIA AND LET'S HAVE A
HEALTHY DEBATE ABOUT WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE THE WE NEED MORE THAN
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN PLACE.
AND THAT'S ON SHOWN BY THE FACT
THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE LEVEL
THE DEVELOPMENT. WITH NOBLE GAS
PROJECTS IN THE STATE THAT WE
ALL THOUGHT WE WOULD BY NOW.
AND FINALLY A ON YOUR POINT AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KRISTIN GARCIA
ABOUT YOUR DISTRICT IT AND IT'S
IN FACT THIS REPRESENT OF MANY
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE. WHERE IT
TURNS OUT TRANSPORTATION SOURCES
ARE A MAJOR SOURCE OF THE
PROBLEM?
NOT ONLY FOR GHG EMISSIONS BUT
FOR THE SMOG FORMING A TOXIC
EMISSIONS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE.
SEEN GREAT PROGRESS IN
TECHNOLOGY DEVELOPMENT ON WITH
ELECTRIC PASSENGER VEHICLES WITH
A HYBRID VEHICLES AND.
WITH A NEAR ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES ON THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD.
JUST IN LAST COUPLE WEEKS
CERTIFIED A NEAR ZERO EMISSION
ENGINE FOR HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
THAT WAS IN MY MIND A MISSING
LINK IN OUR BROAD STRATEGY
TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION STRATEGY THAT WE NOW
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL TOOL. THAT WE
CAN INCENTIVIZE IN USE TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROBLEMS ON THE ROAD WHICH.
WHICH CAN BE THE EMISSIONS OF
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE A A RP AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THAT THOSE
EFFORTS AS WELL THANK YOU.
I WANNA THINK YOU OFFER BEING
HERE ON THE NOW ALLOW MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER SEE A TO DO
CLOSING COMMENTS FOR THE BOTH OF
US THANK YOU I I WILL BE BRIEF I
THINK THE PANELISTS THAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WERE
PRESENT THOSE WHO JUST SPOKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. AND OF COURSE
ALL OF YOU OF US. HAVE REMAIN
HERE PHYSICALLY YAP PATIENTLY
TAKING IN ALL THE INFORMATION
THANK YOU.
AYE WE KNOW THAT WE WILL SEE A
OR B. AGAIN AND.
ITS REPRESENTATIVES CHAIRWOMAN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
AS WELL AS THE LA OFFICE.
ALONG WITH MY DISSIPATE.
A JOINT HEARINGS WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE AGAIN AND
OTHER.
AGENCIES PERHAPS THEY WILL
PARTICIPATE WITH US IN THOSE
HEARINGS.
WE HAD A VERY GOOD CONVERSATION
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT WE
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP ON.
BUT NEVERTHELESS IT'S EXCITING
NIGHT TO BEGIN THE YEAR AND HAVE
THIS THAT ROBUST DISCUSSION.
LASTLY I KNOW THAT WE ARE GOING
TO SEE A ARE BE SOMETIME IN
MARCH THAT WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT.
DDD R. F. EXPENDITURE PLANS
AWARE INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN.
GOING I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
INTEREST IN THAT NOW
CONVERSATIONS AWARE EXCITED TO
BE ABLE TO ENTERTAIN THE
POSSIBILITY OF. HAVING OF THAT
HEARING AS WELL I KNOW SOME
FOLKS IN THE AUDIENCE HAVE
RECOMMENDED PERHAPS SOMETIME IN
THE PRO IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHY A PRO COULD
TELL ABOUT IT WOULD BE. A PLACE
WHERE PEOPLE WOULD WANT TO GO
BUT. AGAIN.
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING THIS.
CONTINUED OUR CONVERSATION WITH
ALL OF YOU THINK YOU CAN IN THIS
A MEETING IS ADJOURNED